Welcome everybody to the [inaudible]
podcast live.
Here we are again.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Thank you.
To stitch fix,
quip express Vpn,
an audible for sponsoring this episode.
And here I sit with you,
the finest men alive.
The boys,
in fact,
more,
uh,
a charity.
A charitably or lovingly.
Yeah,
boys.
Let's say loving English.
The charitable I was,
yeah.
Anyway,
Jack Films and the common etiquette.
God bless them both.
And the soy boy boys are here.
What is the soy boy?
Exactly?
Well,
I'm no expert on the matter.
Uh,
you're the resident.
I think soy is my favorite insult.
Like it used to be cook.
We call people to cook.
It's like whether or not you think it
has any power,
you get called a cocky,
right?
No,
I'm not.
Yeah,
as soy boys even funnier because it's
just like directly attacking your
testosterone levels.
You're just not a man.
You are a soy boy who's got soy in your
veins and you don't eat meat.
Now what is the,
Oh,
it's because you're a vegetarian.
I thought it was because soy makes your
tits bigger.
Yeah.
That's part of the,
it increases estrogen.
Estrogen apparently has estrogen in it.
Wow.
That's,
these guys really know it's a layered
term.
Yeah.
There's a lot going on.
Isn't as popular as cock.
No,
I don't think so.
But it's been on its way for a while.
The stock is rising and falling.
It's hard to genuinely insult somebody
with a phrase like soy boy because it's
somewhat jovial and a thrilling,
I've met more people who like this shirt
for the message of positivity and soy.
Then I have people who are like,
oh,
that's really cute.
Oh,
and it's solely demasculated to eat soy
sauce and these guys Xyz.
Yeah.
They're like,
fuck soy sauce.
Which food?
Overindulges in soy sauce.
And then things was,
so I'd be like,
and not like,
oh,
I mean that said their cholesterol is
probably going to be great because
that's very high in sodium.
That's true.
It's a health thing.
It might be a health thing for them.
Jack,
how are you?
God bless.
Welcome here.
Thank you.
Very,
um,
you're in the Christmas spirit.
My Dude.
What?
What makes you say that even your done
the a Christmas hat section over here.
Back's corner.
I'm trying to get in the spirit because
I was talking with you a little bit
earlier.
Just I'm not in the Christmas spirit yet
and I don't know what,
what the guide is because Christmas is
my favorite freaking holiday and I need
to like wake up and get in that
Christmas spirit.
I don't know if it's like,
just cause it's an outlay,
but I mean like that you've lived in La
for eight years,
so that should be,
and your previous Christmases had been
jolly very,
very few percent valley.
Yeah.
I'm usually like writing music and shit
and now I'm just kinda like,
eh.
So I'm trying to like really get back in
it.
So what do you think's going on?
Why is this Christmas?
I'm,
the jolly levels are a bit lower than
previous years.
I don't know.
Cause like back home we're watching all
of the,
all the lifetime hallmark movies,
every single one and each one worse than
the one after.
It's,
it's absurd.
But we're doing that.
We got all the ornaments and stuff.
Uh,
you guys get gifts to each other where I
think this year we're not going to do
gifts.
We're just kind of over the gifts thing,
but we usually do.
Is that part of the problem?
Yeah,
that's it.
We're not doing yet.
No.
He's like,
dude,
he's like,
it's so much more than that.
Well,
what does it mean to be in the Christmas
spirit?
Because I'm a,
I'm a young Jewish boy.
Eric,
are you Jewish?
No,
I'm a,
I do.
I do Christmas,
but I'm,
I'm with Jack.
I'm not feeling the spirit right now.
You were a Jew.
Can I say that?
Because you've got your name and your
last name is off.
Cut that out and half,
half the comments on my youtube channel
or people calling me that.
So everyone gets it.
That's almost as prevalent as toy.
Yeah.
Well,
they're all the comments to one to get a
combo.
So explain to me a young,
sweet Jewish lad.
Yes.
What does it mean the Christmas spirit?
Because my dad has always been a bit of
a grinch.
Christmas spirit was taken from me.
It helps.
It helps if you just crank the music out
like as loud as you can in every room.
You know you do that well we have
previously so sometimes I would just
like and just play Christmas music.
So let me tell you what's Christmas.
Oh man,
it's a whole world of the Alexa.
Okay.
Oh it's lovely.
I think I might get an back in Israel
like the half that stuff is not cool you
and not going to play that God know God
help us all.
It's because they didn't do an electric
violin version of it for like a snickers
commercial.
That thing has been playing for like 20
years.
Trans Siberian orchestra style.
Is that what it is?
Just to kind of like the rock and roll
shit.
Is that the band that does it though?
It's like I,
so I always get them confused.
Trans Siberian orchestra and then
there's another one and I'm sure you
guys online,
you know what I'm talking about.
I get them mixed up,
but they were both like very synth
heavy,
you know that one is a transfer.
Transunion,
you nailed it.
The Trans Siberian.
Okay.
And that's like they do this,
you know,
very meaty carol of the bells and that's
where they have like the electric
guitar,
that kind of,
yeah,
I feel like you're getting in the
Christmas spirit.
Well see,
okay.
You have it.
And I don't know.
I don't because when I hear Christmas
music on the radio,
I,
I get angry because I swerved at that
because like my favorite station is like
I listened to all these on the radio and
then when November or when like,
yeah,
November after Thanksgiving,
all the way through the new year.
It's the same cricon Christmas music and
I want to hit,
I don't want to hear that shit.
I want to hear actual music that I want
here.
It's just once a year.
Yeah,
swallowed up just one month of the year.
It's like one 12th of my whole year.
No,
the radio was grover late October.
Right.
It's a whole pillar.
They pick it up a little bit.
Like they've got to figure it I think
doing Christmas a long time.
But there is,
I think Hanukkah music is neglected.
I mean Paul Mccartney never wrote a
Hanukkah.
I mean,
everybody's not on the Christmas.
I'm digging into my own Rolodex.
Paul Mccartney wrote Christmas Christmas
song.
What's that really famous one?
He didn't write a Hanukkah song.
He did write a Christmas,
his famous,
Oh God,
that one.
Well man,
I this man,
I'm to get claim just for humming it.
I love Paul Mccartney,
Sir Paul Mccartney,
sir.
To you crunch.
He was knighted.
But that song sucks.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look,
Paul Mccartney,
but that to Paul Mccartney's bullet
bourbon boys.
It's going to take like hot swigs out of
that thing.
What do you want?
Do you guys want,
can we get some glasses in here for the
boys please?
Zola.
I'm good.
Thank you.
Just going to hit that damn skinny Erin.
Badge it.
Look at me.
Pull it apart.
I'm intrigued though by your,
you're having what seems to be an
existential crisis in your life.
Yeah,
just lack of,
I'm just in a weird,
weird shape right now.
It's the Christmas thing.
It's a whole creativity thing,
you know,
burnout,
but it's just,
it's just figuring all that shit.
So I,
I've been through this in my,
in my personal life so many times in my
career and youtube,
but I'm fascinated by it.
It's kind of a self feeding cycle in a
sense.
Are you getting negative comments from
your fans?
Is that feeding it or like are they
supportive?
They've,
lately they've been extremely supportive
and very thankful for that and they
just,
they've been giving me some pretty
solid,
uh,
constructive criticism in the past just
because my,
my videos,
I've just been very stagnant and
quantity or quality I should say.
Is that part of the issue for you?
That is the issue for me.
I just like,
how do I get out of this Rut?
Because all my videos are like a month
ago,
how many theaters were the same and I
hated where I was at and so it's like,
how do I get out of there?
So I'm trying new stuff and getting back
in the groove slowly.
But you know,
it's,
it's not perfect.
I'm fighting it.
What,
what do you do when you're in a Rut?
I was when I'm in a Rut.
Yeah.
Well I was going to say I don't know
what to do.
Oh for,
well no I'm not really.
I was like what's up?
What's the opposite of a rough?
What stops it over Rut of role?
A role.
I'll do it.
I'm in a role in a role,
I'm going to roll down the hill from a
help.
I'm rolling down a hill,
I'm on fire.
You're never in a fucking towards a Rut.
You don't post enough to be in a rush.
No,
that's true.
Definitely.
I guess that would help.
But why don't you,
you're not going to post more.
That will not happen.
Well I think in my cleaning,
you know who would,
what would help that along is if I had
like a studio.
Cause right now I film everything in my
room.
Right.
But if I had like a dedicated space I
could go to and film things in,
uh,
I just like overthink shit before I
start filming it.
Which wouldn't that give like a place,
would that give you incentive to like
get out of bed and go to work?
It's so weird to like,
cause I wake up and then,
oh that's where I'm going all day.
It's just my chair recreation in your
work and your personal life.
This,
this isn't my fed anymore.
This is my tripod and I used to be our
apartment in New York.
It was really rough.
Like yeah,
it's your living room,
your bedroom,
your work wrong.
Everything.
It's nicely.
One tiny.
Yeah.
But you've got ac in there I believe in.
I do finally,
finally got a seat.
Awesome.
But I'm never going to use it too
offensive or what?
No,
I just like being sweaty so I just want
it to have it.
I'll use it when I'm editing,
but I will say,
um,
Jack,
the will smith fit you made was
fantastic.
The comments were great.
Everyone was very happy.
That must've made you feel jolly.
That put me in the Christmas spirit
right away.
That's true.
Certainly helps.
I don't know if that was great seeing
the feedback.
Like so many comments were like the old
Jack is back and that's,
to me that's the highest praise cause
that's where I'm trying to get back to
outcomes on wonder if that's like,
cause I've been there,
people have been telling me they miss
the old ethan forever,
but it's have like case from the dragon
to hear that.
I hate hearing that even when it's in a
good way because they mean the best.
But it's still,
it's a double edge to compliment.
You don't want to,
you need to,
you just,
it's hard not to look back but you kind
of have to not,
yeah,
you shouldn't,
it.
I think it's amb because well first off
senses of humor do evolve over time and
shit.
I found funding five years ago,
even two years ago.
I don't find funny now.
I find it funny in a different way.
I do feel like sometimes I,
I gotta go back in the archives and
figure out what was I doing back then
that was that I just wouldn't even think
of.
Sometimes it's like that's where he gets
explained.
Know what it was.
I find when I look back on my live
videos,
it's not so much that like I was doing
something,
it's just,
it's really about the state of mind
because you're in a healthy place in
your mind,
you doubt yourself less.
You question yourself less and you're,
when you're,
I find that when I'm in a better head
space,
I'm always making better stuff.
So I've found that it's very much about
how I'm feeling rather than something
specifically I'm doing.
And you kind of like just fearlessly,
just like making shit and moving on.
Yeah.
I liked that.
I,
I just get in these like that's a good
way to put it.
Cause I do,
I pace around the house like all day.
It's just,
it's,
it's sad.
Right.
Are you just trying to think of ideas
and I'm talking to myself,
fleshing out ideas and jokes.
Is this funny and will this work?
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
being in the right state of mind I think
would work wonders in therapy.
I am not in therapy personally.
Um,
but for me it's been huge because I been
in a,
and I always thought of therapy has
some,
like I was like,
Ooh,
fucking smell your own asshole while
you're at it.
Therapy.
But I swear to God it's helped me a lot
and I think it actually helped me get
out of my rut because there's so much
other shit going on.
It's,
it's hard to,
it's really so hard to step out of
yourself and see what's the actual
problem.
It's a lot of the times the real problem
is not something that you are addressing
or even aware of.
And that honestly has been really
valuable to me.
How once a week,
twice a year,
I go once a week.
He tells me I need to come twice a week,
but he's like,
you really ought to come twice a week,
dude.
You're fucked up.
You did therapy or no,
but I have,
you have,
it's great.
You're cured.
You know,
it's like a,
it's like pausing your netflix
subscription.
There's just nothing on right now that
it needs my attention.
Yeah,
I got it.
That's beautiful metaphor.
But,
uh,
yeah,
there's,
there shouldn't be a stigma about
therapy even though the,
you know,
people like to put one there just
because it's like,
well I'm not going to one,
so I must be good.
And then a week later,
like their grandma dies and it's like,
yeah,
I you,
she might want to unravel that yarn.
Yeah.
Are you,
why,
is there a reason you haven't considered
therapy or you just felt like you
haven't needed it
but you never get over the ladder?
I've just never put much thought into
it.
It's not that I don't believe in it
cause I,
I,
I'm,
I'm sure it would do me good.
It's just one of those,
I just haven't pursued it because it's a
whole thing.
It's a whole thing and I'm not,
and I'm not knocking it.
I'm sure I could,
I could absolutely benefit from it.
I just,
I dunno,
I feel like I got to figure,
I don't know,
I say I got to figure it out,
but I know therapy would help if it,
well the thing is
stuck in a Rut for so long and I was at,
I was just,
I wasn't like super irritable and I was
super just like,
like I was always trying to get out of
it and run and run and run and I was
just running like a hamster wheel.
I don't know if this is your situation,
I'm just totally on my own person,
but I felt like I was in a hamster wheel
for like a whole year just running and
was getting worse and worse and worse.
Yeah.
And so I just had like a breaking point
where I started taking medicine and
started going to therapy and I think
that was like three months ago.
But I tell you that life change you.
That's fantastic man.
I guess,
I mean what was the story is not your
therapist coming on the show cut.
Actually,
I think I hear him laughing back.
Good dance.
My staff.
You want to make sure I love that one.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
The last time I went to him,
he's like,
I really think you should come twice a
week.
I was like,
man,
I don't,
it's too much.
Yeah,
you got to have your foot down
somewhere.
Oh Wow.
Holy.
So I'm not supposed to drink alcohol,
but I'm also don't want to be a grinch.
Well either.
Definitely can't drink all,
but she's got a bun in the oven and
you're not drinking.
She's drinking.
I'm not drinking cause my,
cause apparently on antidepressants
you're not supposed to drink alcohol,
but does anyone really care about that?
I apologize.
Oh,
here's me and Jack's therapy.
That's to that.
Cheers down the hat.
Bad luck.
Bad luck did not.
Here's another alcohol drink.
It's like a dyno.
So pregnant women cursing look.
So I just avoid ladders.
That's all I'm going to say.
Okay.
Who Curse too?
Did I curse you or did you curse me?
Well,
I have the alcohol,
so I think we're all cars.
All right.
You guys want to watch some of it?
You want to watch some shit?
I know for this,
uh,
show me the videos.
What's the,
what's good on the,
what's going on the Boob tube man?
Have you seen youtube?
Rewind,
rewind.
What's that?
Uh,
I actually haven't seen that.
I saw,
I think eric and walk the fuck is in
there for me.
Should we walk in together and we watch
together or is that old news?
I feel like everybody,
my password is all,
I mean we can get eric's live grashen at
Youtube.
We want,
that's pretty special.
Interesting.
I don't know if it's redundant.
I'll just be staring into this camera.
Like it's the office,
the whole,
um,
oh,
I do want to make a couple of
announcements before we proceed.
Tuesday's our big annual charity stream
with Justin Reuland alk search.
We've got it bigger and badder than
ever.
So,
and also post Malone is donating a smash
guitar signed for the Raffle as well as
many other items.
Joey Salads is here.
He's going to eat progressively hotter
peppers at every milestone.
We have a little kiddie pool full of
milk.
He's going to put on a life vest,
little rubber duckies and a whole scoop
of gear.
Sit in a pool of milk and eat
progressively hotter peppers all the way
up to Carolina reaper.
No,
he's flying in for this.
Yeah,
this is a big event.
This is huge.
Can I be the set medic?
You're qualified fire extinguisher.
Also on Friday.
We want to do the best and worst of the
ace treat podcast.
Let's hope this looks so different.
God,
it's going to be,
it's going to be rough.
Senior submissions to
podcast@atriusreproductions.com
for your best and worst.
So let's skip.
Let's skip youtube.
Rewind.
Let's uh oh,
this is amazing.
So this year you guys are going,
Mark Walberg you know it's funny to see
mark these days cause we saw him
recently in a movie with Tom Segura.
What was the name of that movie?
That instant family and he's a great
movie and it's such a wholesome,
fun and he's such,
he's got this wholesome vibe now.
But here's mark back in the nine.
Real goofy,
pretty boy.
Listen to how he talks.
He throws on like an accent but then he
drops a line in here that is will become
iconic.
Sounds goes out to my man Calvin Klein.
Good looking out for the drawers.
Not Saying I would do it.
Not the fruit of the loom commercial or
nothing like that.
Cause they don't make the hype shorts.
These,
these are the nineties man.
They just fit good and it hold,
hold me,
snuck.
So from about to go get some skins,
I'm not going to put on like no silk
underwear.
Oh she got freckles.
He talks like a youtube pranksters who
she got freckles.
She got freckles.
Light gets better.
There's no other way.
He's definitely got like a sock in his
pants.
Look at that lump look.
Fix My poop.
He's got a big one.
Yeah,
not that big.
It looks like an egg plant.
You're right.
It's cool.
It's just a fucking that shit.
And I don't think it's supposed to fit
like a diaper dude.
Fucking mount vesuvius down there.
But here we go.
The real one does edits when they
removed the music to make it awkward.
Hi,
this is,
this is real is again,
I thought it was just like,
Oh really?
The nineties that's just how they did
it.
Yeah.
The middle of our money on mark.
This is real.
Like a real APP.
Yes.
Oh,
okay.
Here it comes.
No,
the best protection against a,
just to keep the cow and so on.
That's protecting against AIDS.
Keep your Calvin's on.
Well,
does that mean if he puts his dick
through the hole,
then who doesn't get aids?
Maybe it's the kind that doesn't
separate.
You know there's so many things wrong.
Well yeah,
sure.
We can unpack.
Mostly you could still get aids with
those on,
I guarantee it.
They're using like the aids scare of the
nineties to sell fucking underwear.
Yeah.
That's outstanding.
Girl.
You got,
hey,
it's doesn't matter.
You sit on your couch.
You're good.
Yo Baby,
let me fuck you through my calvins.
Believeable that's the body.
Calvin's best way to prevent AIDS is
keep it on your couch.
I guess he's saying as you promoting
celibacy,
is that what he's doing?
What is that like?
Not having sex?
Keeping us.
Andy feels like flirting with her.
The message doesn't make sense cause
he's absolutely promoting celibacy and
yet at the same time he just wants a
hand guy.
Yeah,
that's the wine they cut out at the end.
The suite to prevent aids.
Get a hand guy.
I'm Marty.
No,
another take.
Okay.
Oh okay.
That wasn't,
that was what does Nancy Reagan knew me
to say seriously or wait,
who was it that was,
cause guys remember like in sex ed every
time it was like,
okay,
here's the different steps of protection
you can take but really don't have sex.
Right.
Absolutely.
What is the time I had some wild lessons
in sex ed.
Did you guys like I had one teacher,
I had a lot of conservative teachers.
I don't know why.
One teacher told our whole class
straight up,
she said,
guys,
women do not sex.
I'm telling you right now the female
orgasm is a myth.
Whoa darth.
She told her whole class,
she's like,
women do not enjoy sex and I had watched
a lot of porn in my life by then and I
was like,
that is not the impression I got.
And I and I,
well I know porn oversells it,
but I was really common ties with that
cause I was like,
Whoa,
like what a terrible thing.
I'll never forget it.
So just,
you know,
get yours all rate.
I mean kind of I guess.
I guess her point was that you put it in
and make a baby and then you take it
out.
She got her across shit wrong.
Neither party should enjoy it.
Abstinence,
that was what they always called it in
sex ed.
I went to be abstinent Catholic middle
school and that was absolutely,
what did they tell you about condoms at
all?
They did,
but they were heavily frowned upon.
Just just don't do it.
Like if you absolutely have to sin,
they put like fish hooks through it.
Just how they come.
Yeah,
we call it these are condoms,
Aka Satan's hand mouth.
Right.
The heat up real hot.
They burn you and they only have a 50%
success rate.
Just don't even try children.
We call these Satan's butthole.
It's like putting your Dick and Satan's
butthole.
When you put a condom on,
school's great,
but he's there.
What was sex ed like in Israel?
It was like one class where they teach
you,
I mean,
not like a onetime session,
they're just like,
here we go,
guys,
birds and bees.
One would come like not that teacher or
someone else would come and they'd
demonstrate like a cute come there.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
it's like straight out of like freaks
and kick.
I don't really remember it.
This is a very short,
then everyone was feeling awkward.
Yeah.
I remember they showed us gnarly
pictures of like std written penises.
Really?
That oh yeah.
Like unbelievable.
Like projector,
like real big guys.
Like a penis.
Like the only way I can describe it as
like a lion's mane of chlamydia,
they would only show,
I see illustrations.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
I'd be a lot happier and healthier
today.
Or if it was,
we got illustrations,
Jack would be in the Christmas spirit.
Reminds me,
I have that clear.
Which the situation,
I know he taught.
He taught it.
Yeah.
So,
oh,
about the celibacy.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm sorry.
I'm the situation indicating celibacy
while,
so it was a sweet message cause um,
you had on one hand,
uh,
what's her name?
The girl who ran with uh,
uh,
Mccain Pailin,
Sarah Palin's daughter who has like
three kids out of wedlock advocating for
celibacy and then the,
she might hit you get it.
That might get people to be sellable.
I mean you're a hypocrite,
but don't gain right.
Here we go.
Let's see.
The situation may have watched it on the
podcast.
So we have Washington did a long time
ago.
Yeah.
Did you guys know that?
If he called Mark Walberg Marky mark,
he gets really mad.
No,
I didn't like that.
Oh really?
But that should be like a term of
endearment.
Like it's a nickname.
I think it's like a rebranding thing.
He's just like,
oh,
shut up and names.
By the way,
you know when he was young he like beat
the shit of a Chinese guy.
Made a blind.
Yeah,
I read about a lot of trouble for that.
Some did blind,
right.
I don't,
I think he's like,
he's handled that by just like burying
it,
but like,
it keeps coming up every couple of years
on reddit where people,
like today I learned Marky Mark,
uh,
nearly killed the guy.
Did you know,
here's the one with the crazy schedule,
right?
Yeah.
Story.
Mr 3:00
AM I don't get that.
You don't have to wake up at 3:00
AM.
That doesn't impress me.
You can wake up at 6:00
AM and still do as much.
What's a,
what?
What was his bedtime if you woke up at
three?
We watch that as much.
That anything to watch.
This is a still photo,
right?
Grand Post.
Like a picture of his schedule.
Oh,
I thought he had a video talking about
it for a bit with him.
They like,
he,
I think the host James Corden and tried
to um,
like live a life,
live it day in the life of Mark Walberg
view of that whole sketch.
It was like I'm trending throughout the
fucking morning.
Believable.
Well that's just not,
that's not admirable.
That's just,
that's lunacy.
Yeah,
it is.
Vanity is what it is.
What time do you go to bed when you wake
up at three kids and shit.
It's eight.
You don't live a life.
If you only ate like earlier,
you don't.
You work on picture day.
I mean like I don't believe that this is
a daily schedule for the guy.
Maybe when he's like,
I don't know,
Mark Wahlberg's insane workout schedule
starts at two 30 in the morning.
That's ridiculous.
Is this guy superhuman?
Well,
no.
He just goes to bed at eight like a
fucking nine year old.
What a what?
A nerd.
What a point.
He goes to bed at seven 30 he looked
correct.
The record.
Imagine going to bed at seven 30 Oh my
God.
Imagine being famous and wealthy and
achieving everything you've ever wanted
in life and going to bed at seven 30
doesn't that undermine El success?
My night doesn't start til like 10 more.
There's a picture of the schedule right
here.
We got a typical daily schedule.
Cryo chamber.
I'm sorry,
that was the first thing that cryo
chamber recall.
That's the secret,
right?
It's prayer time.
Beg,
but nine to 45 Scott,
thank God he prays for 30 minutes.
That's a,
that's a hell of the prayer.
He's got the rosary and a half.
God,
please don't let me get in more trouble
for that shit.
That guy,
please Jesus.
Please don't call me Marky mark today.
They dropped dead.
Oh,
I'll make him blind.
Dear Lord.
Post workout meal,
shower,
golf.
This motherfucker's got time to pray at
Okay.
But to be fair,
nobody calls for 30 minutes,
half hour.
So something that he does,
he's,
he's whacking off something else now.
It's probably got a little tea.
Maybe like a little,
a green background or something.
Yeah.
It's just time and golf at home.
He's got 30 minutes for a snack.
What a cutie pie or does he have like a
box of juice and some crackers?
No,
no,
no.
That's wrong.
He has an hour and a half of snack time.
Oh my God.
It's 90 minutes.
Boys allocate that time more to golf or
something.
And then he has another snack
immediately after that.
So he's just usually snacking.
All want to live in it up and he's
definitely a snacking in the cryo
chamber.
Like what else do you do in there?
Isn't there for an hour?
Yeah.
11:00
AM family time.
It's like,
all right,
everybody gather around.
We go way our,
well careful.
He also has a sandwich in meetings and
work calls,
so it's family time,
but he's on the phone the whole time.
Oh,
I loved how filling.
They don't even get their own hour.
Yeah,
but it doesn't take an hour for lunch.
He has marky mark.
He's like,
okay,
everybody leave lunch tonight.
We made fun of a lot of people,
the four of us when we're all together,
but this is the first time I've been
afraid that like they're going to kick
this fucking door down and just
[inaudible] it'll make you blind in one
eye.
Are Making the jokes about me.
Huh?
Real sensitive voice of the apes.
I heard you guys were the,
he's got kind of a Mike Tyson thing with
a real sensitive was I thought you guys
were making jokes about me.
I just want to tell you,
he has like the sensitive,
I just want to tell you guys get across
that it's not cool that you guys making
fun of me.
He looks like he's always explaining to
a kid why they can't buy a present.
Wow.
Is that really accurate?
I just don't even get that right.
Right.
And it was like your mom's going to see
you come back with,
it's just can be really mad and that's
solid nail.
Can I say something though?
I actually loved that shtick.
I'm very charmed by it.
Yeah.
The ship being white,
his voice,
no one has like sensitive tough guy.
I love that character.
So I'm,
oh,
I fall for it.
Write books.
All the big C book.
I worked on a movie that he was in.
Tell me about the experience.
It was a,
the lovely bones,
the loveliest,
the lovely bones.
I was like,
uh,
an additional PA crew member swing guy
in there somewhere and got to like a
weekend.
But I got to see him walking around on
set.
I'll tell you,
he was always in a good mood.
He was whistling,
singing a cup,
coffee in his hand,
just bopping along like the little soy
soy boy.
I'm sure he was like this dude was,
he really got a stain on it.
I really should have gotten this thing
dry clean before the stain does not come
with this.
I don't think you need to dry clean
that.
I mean cause Nah so positive.
He probably goes in his trailer
and like punches punching someone in the
face.
I like to warn me about like eye contact
or anything like that.
Did you hear about with celebrities but
right,
right.
Just looking at it wrong.
That's a weird,
that's required.
Don't make I Oakland like there's
stories about that's appearance Hannity.
Really super good actor.
Who liked did Lincoln,
what's his name?
Daniel Day Lewis.
No eye contact.
No,
the opposite.
Uh,
eye contact.
All right.
If that was accurate as needed then like
the best actor would need that for like
his method acting.
It's like I get it.
You look him in the eyes.
He fucks up his character shit.
But he was like between takes on
Lincoln,
just like chilling with the crew and
like telling stories and stuff and can,
there we go.
All right.
No,
just out of character.
It was like,
all right,
let's go again.
And he said,
oh,
I'm thinking,
wow.
So I mean maybe that's just how good he
is.
That's a problem.
It makes me doubt the whole eye contact
thing that it's like a performance
issue.
Oh yeah.
There's actors being divas on that
point.
What do I know him?
Well,
I swapped boy command.
I don't allow Ian to look me in the eye.
Yeah,
but that's like dominance thing.
I just feel like I have to,
I'm just like,
whoa.
Even careful with that.
I contacted,
I already warned you twice.
You just like,
all right,
we're going to take a break.
Fans yelling at me.
Nice.
We're going to take a quick break.
We'll be right back.
The boys are just back in town and we're
only beginning.
We've only watched like one video of
100,000.
That's right.
We'll be right back.
Stitch fix is an online personal styling
service.
They find it delivers clothes,
shoes,
and accessories to fit your body budget
and lifestyle.
Now Dan's got a sweater he got from them
that he frankly has never taken off and
it looks good on them.
It's like they read your mind and said,
hey,
this is the perfect sweater for Dan.
Dan,
would you agree yes or no?
Absolutely.
There it is folks.
This is how it works.
You'd go to their website,
you take a survey about your style that
show you pictures of clothing to rate
how you like it to figure out your style
so they have a good idea of what you
like.
You just go to stitch fix.com/h
street,
tell them your sizes,
what you like,
how much you want to spend,
and boom,
Bob's your uncle.
You get some awesome clothes in the
mail.
You'll be paired with your very own
personal stylist who will hand pick
items and sent right to your door.
You try them on.
You only pay for what you love.
You return the breasts.
Shipping exchanges and returns are
always free,
my dude,
so there's no subscription required.
You could sign up to receive scheduled
shipments or get your fix whenever you
want.
Styling fees are only 20 bucks and it's
applied towards anything you keep from
your shipment.
So it's pretty much free.
Here's what we're doing.
Get started right fricking.
now@stitchfix.com
slash h three and you'll get 25% off
when you keep all items in your box that
stitch fix.com/hp
to get started today.
Sticks stitch fix dot slash h three here
is the last tooth brush you will ever
need.
It's quip as the perfect Christmas gift.
It's high tech but at an affordable
price.
This an amazing electric toothbrush.
It's got soft,
perfect bristles because gums are
sensitive and you do not want to damage
your gums because let me tell you about
gums folks.
They do not grow back and you're going
to find that out later in life can be
like,
dammit,
I wish I listened to Ethan and got to
quit.
Not only that,
it tells you when to switch sides so it
vibrates vibe,
fry rates.
Oh 30 seconds.
Switch sizes.
So you know,
and it turns off when you're done.
So you always get the perfect dentist
recommended brush.
This is my favorite to approach.
I will not use any other toothbrush.
It's also got a tongue scraper on the
back so you can get all of that nasty
shit on your off of your tongue and have
that beautiful kissable breadth and
beautiful teeth and mouth that you
deserve.
God it because,
let me be frank and square with you all
there.
Nothing,
nothing,
nothing worse than a disgusting mouth.
That's it.
If I smell your breath,
if I see you,
don't take good care of your teeth.
I'm out right Ila as a girl,
trimet.
So here,
that's why I love quip.
And they've got over 5,000
verified five star reviews to back it
up.
All right,
so,
so it starts at only 25 bucks.
What?
Gotu get quip.com/h
through right now you get your first
refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush.
But you don't have to tell your gift.
He that well about that big of a deal.
They're like,
well,
don't,
don't tell him.
I got the refill for freight.
That's your,
but it is a hookup.
That's your first refill.
Pack free at [inaudible] dot com slash h
with all the recent news about online
security breaches,
it's hard not to worry about where my
data goes.
Make an online purchase or simply access
your email could put your private
information at risk.
You're being tracked online all the time
by social media sites,
marketing companies,
and you're mobile and Internet provider.
That's why you need to take your
Internet privacy back right now.
Use an express vpn experts.
VPN has easy to use.
APPS that run seamlessly in the
background of any computer,
phone and tablet.
Turning on express VBM protects
protection only takes one click.
I'll tell you what takes more than one
click trying to get your identity and
your data back after it's lost.
Try Getting back your credit card,
your stolen credit card information in
the money that people scammed off after.
Yeah,
that's more than one click.
One Click now.
Express vpn secures and then optimizes
your Internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public ip
address.
Protect yourself with express vpn costs
of less than $7 a month.
Protect yourself online to day and find
out how you can get three months free
and express vpn.com/h
street that's e x p r e s s vpn.com/age
three for three months free with a one
year package.
Visit Express vpn.com/
[inaudible] to learn more.
What would it look like if we all
listened to more?
Well,
listening to audio books motivates,
sets inspire as us and even brings us
closer together.
And if you'll recall,
I asked Jordan Peterson our audio books
as good as reading and he said yes,
of course.
I wondered that they're just as good
baby even better.
And I'll tell you why.
You can multitask,
you can exercise,
you can game,
you can even sleep.
I don't know how much you'll absorb,
but you can't do that.
Audio books are good for any activity,
whatever it is enhancing and makes it
better for our audience.
Audible is offering a free audio book
when you start a 30 day trial.
So you got no risk,
baby.
Just give it a shot.
If you want to listen to it audibles got
it.
Just go to audible.com/h
street podcast or text hd podcast to 500
500 and browse there unmatched selection
of audio content.
Start Your 30 day trial.
Download an audio book for free and
start listening.
It's that easy.
There's no better place to listen than
audio than audible because now audible
gives members even more exclusive audio
fitness programs and audio books,
audible originals,
and more.
And now with audible originals,
you can experience even more custom
content made exclusive for audible
members.
Here's the stuff that I get into on
audible.
They've got all of the Lord of the rings
trilogy.
They've got all of the Harry potters,
they've got all of the game of thrones,
they've got all of the best Sagas and
series like that,
and you've just got so many hours of
great content,
acted out,
narrated by incredible actors.
You've got to give any one of these
series if you're interested in,
you're going to love it over at audible
every month as audible as an audible
member,
you get one credit.
Good for any audio book you choose.
Plus to audible originals from a
changing selection you can't get
anywhere else.
Audible members also get access to audio
fitness and health workouts created
exclusively for audible.
Plus your books are yours to keep with
audible.
You can go back and re listen anytime.
Even if you cancel your membership,
they don't like your audio book exchange
it,
no questions asked.
So here's the offer guys,
start a 30 day trial and your first
audio book is free.
Go to audible.com/h
street podcast or text h through podcast
to 500 500 that's a U D I b l
e.com/podcast
or text a street podcast to 500 500 we
are back.
Welcome.
Uh,
how was the break for you guys?
You guys all enjoyed yourselves and it
was really nice break.
I actually didn't want it to end bonding
to go back to sleep.
Please.
Actually I brought my oh switch.
If we could just play a little smashed
for a couple of hours.
Have you been playing smash?
All I want to be absolutely.
Absolutely.
Get out of the eye line down.
I know you guys don't look at me.
Don't look,
oh wait,
wait.
So what does being in someone's eyeline
mean?
Cause that doesn't even sound like
making eye contact,
but just me and like,
you know,
like this camera right here,
if there's somebody standing to the left
of it,
you're like kind of,
you know,
drawn to them.
Like you want to look at two and you're
seeing what's,
while you're acting,
if anybody that walks in the back and
it's kind of like,
it makes your eyes jiggle a little bit.
It's kind of weird,
but like at the same time it's very easy
to your professional.
Yeah.
And it just ruins the illusion though.
I mean,
nobody's standing next to a camera,
like in the case of,
you know,
some diva that wants that kind of shit.
Nobody's saying next to the camera going
like this.
Fuck up.
Come on.
Fuck it up.
I wonder.
I'll be like looking at my eye line
holding the camera.
So recently,
uh,
let's see,
Google's see,
oh went before Congress and one member
of Congress,
a congress.
What was his name?
Larry fucking old as hell.
Is this the iphone guy?
What's his name?
I believe a Steve King.
Steve King Vixxo or no,
no relation.
He has this question for the c o one of
the most powerful men in the world
really come before Congress humbles
himself before our government.
And this is the question that our best
and brightest elected officials have for
the CEO of Google.
I have a seven year old granddaughter
who picked up her phone before the
election and she just playing a little
game kinda game a kid would play and
upon their pops a picture of her
grandfather,
and I'm not going to say into their
record what is the kind of language was
used around that picture of her
grandfather.
But I'd ask you,
how does that show up on a seven year
old's iphone,
who's playing a kid's game?
Congressmen,
a iphone is made by a different company.
And so,
you know,
I mean I might've been an Android,
I was just,
it was a hand me down at some guidance.
Uh,
you know,
wait,
can I pause?
I have questions.
I'm happy to what's going on with this
guy in the backseat,
the monopoly guy protest.
You can,
you can do that.
I think she's a female.
She,
we've seen,
I've seen her.
I believe it's,
if it's the same person she was at
something else,
another hearing,
another congressional hearing where she
dressed up in the exact same attire,
adjusted the monocle.
It's that easy to get in there.
Well,
I don't know how to the public hearing
come in later.
If I had to guess,
I would say the mustache wasn't on,
oh,
you mean the entered?
I,
I disagree.
I think they pull off right now and that
she got a prime location to it.
Like that's a good headline.
Immediately caught my eye when the guy
was like,
the answer the question.
I've washed his feet of several times
and now I'm just noticing this person
up.
It's the guy's dribbling a basketball,
but there's a gorilla walking in the
background.
That's one of those videos.
So let's continue.
We're almost more litigation,
which was being used,
which,
uh,
had a specification,
but I'm happy to understand it better
and clarify it for you.
Okay.
That's thank you for your testimony and
yield back the balance sheets that,
I'm sorry,
what is he complaining about?
A picture of,
uh,
of him,
I guess he said of her grandpa came up
on her phone.
Now how does that happen on the iphone?
And he's like,
well,
I'm from Google.
First of all,
I think we have to take into
consideration this guy doesn't know what
the fuck he's talking.
Well yeah,
I think,
yeah,
but like imagine you've got this guy
historically powerful person and you're
throwing this dump.
Like even if it was the wrong company,
just imagine asking like,
why is there,
why is this picture on my phone?
How could that happen?
Mark people making fun of me.
Yeah.
Can you tell me line of all places?
Um,
there's a little a and there's a couple
of flaws to his lodge.
Oh,
Dan.
Not ever use the Internet apparently.
Well,
no,
and I think that's a big problem with
our government is that it's run by an
old bunch of old fucks who are still
using aol.com
and they're trying to fix like global
warming and they're like,
hold on baby,
let me,
uh,
let me dial up real quick and check the
science check this side.
Yay will says it's all good.
I got a few more free hours left
according to this.
Hold on baby.
I'm waiting for my,
my cd in the mail.
Yeah,
I just got 30 free hours.
This guy in this chat room said there's
nothing to worry about.
Yeah,
Dale's all he says it's all good.
You know,
I read something and it may be total
bullshit,
but it makes sense that there's still
millions of people paying aol dial up to
this day.
Let's break that down.
Millions of people.
Where are these in the states are
gathered throughout the states.
Florida,
Florida is a Florida man,
probably Florida.
Grandma,
Florida,
grandma.
I would be surprised if my grandparents
were still paying aol.com
dial up.
Can you imagine?
That's like,
that's amazing.
How,
like,
how would they learn though,
to upgrade to,
um,
not dial up,
you know,
to where they learn.
Presumably a grandson who's better than
me,
but I'm justifying their,
their,
um,
no.
Yeah,
no,
they're,
they're faultless fusion.
Wow.
Confused.
No,
there they are faultless because they
didn't even understand it when it came
out back then.
They were old.
Now they're super old.
Pick that up pretty quickly.
Yeah.
So like,
you know,
we've,
we've got that,
that is our responsibility.
Like,
you know,
they're supposed to not kill the
environment.
Leave us some fucking money for our
retirement funds.
All we have to do is plug their
computers each way so they can get their
emails.
I haven't viruses twice as fast.
That's true.
Well mean they shouldn't have fast
internet.
That's a really good point because
there's a huge problem of people preying
on old people and scheming money.
So I'm gonna call my grandma once and
said,
um,
impersonated me.
They had all my information when I was
in college.
It was before I was known to anybody and
they say,
hey,
it's ethan.
He probably didn't sound anything like
me,
but she's old as fuck on a land line.
It says,
Hey,
it's Ethan,
I'm trapped in Mexico and I'm arrested
and I need you to send me $5,000
bail.
And she was going to do it and my
brother was there luckily,
and stop.
That's awful.
But like apparently I saw like a $2
billion business,
just scamming old people.
That's so sad.
There's fake irs calls that are really
getting a lot of attention these days
and they're all from India,
but they will get an from the irs.
So you pay now?
Yeah.
I don't know if there was like a voice
modulator that made them sound like they
were some like southern good old boy,
they would get so much more.
I,
why am I giving them ideas?
Shut the fuck up.
God Damn.
To pick up on that,
they're going to start taking like
southern jacqueline voice coaches.
Yes.
Southern gentlemen for Halo Dolores.
And now it says here that uh,
you need to go to the irs had dot irs
pay right now.
That,
uh,
fun.
Delores,
bad news.
There's a warrant out for your day are
going to be in a lot of trouble.
They're going to kick your door down and
you know the police so they will shoot
your dog.
Yeah,
that's start.
That is kind of close to the,
some of the stuff I've heard.
Oh,
the teacher sounds great.
You've got yes.
I can't wait.
Can I buy stock in that do when we were
on up by Robin Hood App,
we're going to be shiny and centers and
I'd Oh video with that character and
devout.
He found another one.
Yeah,
hands on.
It gets around.
Holy Shit.
140,000
this is big news is,
well that's three days ago,
so this is probably the same.
Dan,
can you hook me up with a coke?
Zero.
Sure.
Damn.
She's got a lot of silos on her face.
You got a little [inaudible].
It's like,
I don't want to hit your Sodi.
Okay,
Sharon.
I look,
oh I got,
I'll share with Ila.
Be really cute if I'll take my old
Saudi.
It's Christmas.
Absolutely.
That's the Christmas spirit compromise.
Fuck.
I go leave it on the ground and walk
away for 30 minutes.
Sit.
Pray.
This is a coke Marshville that
refreshing Christmas season.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay Robbie,
let's enjoy when they click
privacy policy,
you get,
they look at the ceiling of his or down
is going to use
this guy's like,
that's awesome.
I mean this guy is just like,
I feel bad for the CEO.
Oh this guy is amazing.
How does he know every,
I mean I guess it's easy to know when
the camera's on you,
but like he clicks into it every time
the camera cuts to him.
He's got great timing really.
It really does.
Great framing.
Right?
Awareness might be right.
Maybe it is a sheet so,
well it's hard.
It's hard for me to tell him this video
but the,
the older video from like a few months
ago,
100% cause she,
cause like she gave interviews in
character but this,
this person could be a gentleman.
I offer those same thing.
It's a person.
He or she with a top hat.
Uh,
they're dressed as of that Amapa Lee guy
with the,
and they got a sack of money with them,
like $20 bills popping out at the top.
Very,
and they look very intrigued.
Everyone else dress like super
professional camera equipment
everywhere.
Yeah.
Just this guy knocked on a monocle.
Holy Shit.
What is the angle here?
Is this guy just having a laugh?
Is this a Geico commercial?
The bag cause like Geico on it.
Honestly,
if I'd thought of that first and I lived
in the area,
I would do that.
Yeah.
They're making some statement.
Um,
not,
I mean like truthfully there being some
political statement about,
I don't even know what they're saying.
One day everyone in the audience is
going to be like,
it's going to grow.
Like go be two of them.
It was really out of control.
I can't write,
I can't shoot without nobody's taking
these hearings.
God,
this guy's getting a lot of airtime and
he's loving this.
How our privacy is up for sale.
I guess one of those things,
whereas we don't have this dude's like
twitter or anything.
What I'm saying?
Is he sharing credit?
Can they not hold up the sign?
That's like following me on twitter at
that would be a real thing.
Not as cool.
That's just smart marketing yet.
Actually I just found,
uh,
they actually did an ama on reddit.
There you go.
So all your questions will be answered.
Why two of them?
I guess we're not that [inaudible] guys,
I'm here to take two questions.
Who are you and why?
Okay.
Thank you for coming to my ame.
Um,
porn hub put together the world's most
viewed categories of porn at 2018 by
geographical location.
I love it.
This says a lot.
Now what fascinates me the most,
you'll see there's some interest.
The U s loves lesbian,
who doesn't all south of America really
loves lesbian Chile,
however Thai and all over Asia,
all of Asia.
I think so many people in Japan are
watching Hentai.
They fucked up the whole continent.
Like Japan.
I get it.
Russia,
I'm very surprised.
It's got to be all of the eastern block.
Actually.
It's like all of the former Soviet
Union.
That blows my mind that,
I mean I've tried Hentai just out of
pure curiosity.
It's so weird.
Real porn available.
Yeah.
I just jerk off the captain planet.
Does that,
should I move to Russia?
Good.
The live action porn,
but cartoon girl.
So I'm,
I'm shocked about Russia because
normally when I see these types of
graphs and bar charts and such,
um,
the,
the most repressed places,
so like if if gay porn or if gay art is
just largely banned and frowned upon,
then usually that territory has gay
porn.
You know,
that's like,
they're,
they're like states in the u s it's all
about that.
Or anytime the Republican national
convention comes to the,
exactly.
So that's why I'm shocked about Russia
since like,
you know,
being gay is a big no,
no.
In Russia,
they're all about the Hentai.
Like if you,
if you grain new,
if you took a closer look,
because when I've seen that where you're
talking about like in the u s like in
Kansas everyone's watching gay porn or
whatever.
Um,
but it's so broad.
What is the green one?
The green.
Well,
so you've got Arab porn,
which is in North Africa and the one and
then ebony and all in Africa,
which is black.
I find that interesting that people,
they're trying,
they want to get down with their own
shit.
And then South as South East Asia you've
got Asian.
Can I just say my favorite is big Dick.
It's Pakistan,
right?
And an end in India.
Their favorite like mills,
the mills man,
the weirdest ones.
Look at Spain.
Spain stands alone.
What is it?
Oh there's a lot of uh,
anal.
Sure.
Oh that's different than a stop mill.
Beyond that,
beyond pile the cougar champs.
Beyond mill.
Like old as fuck.
Cause I was going to say basically are
technically all porn is mature,
but if it's an early audience is weird.
Really.
All those people I would guess like,
it's like Kyle Milf I would say is like
30 to 50 mature is like 60 plot.
Like paint.
Like damn.
I did all about it from Spain
apparently.
How does the whole country perhaps
further analyze,
oh wait,
what's that?
To the east?
Yeah.
I honestly don't know.
For instance to the east.
Yeah,
that one was that.
Oh,
oh,
that's gotta be like the Romania.
I will get us from a fucking idiot.
Germany.
Germany's into anal England is into anal
what was right again?
No,
that is lesbian.
This is Germany.
No,
Germany.
But what you pointed to was not,
anyway.
Oh fuck me.
Here it is.
Tomorrow's vote.
What is this?
Norway.
Youtube for our shit.
That's actually Sweden,
Norway,
Finland,
all the same place.
I got that one right.
You get eaten alive for that.
Can I say Europeans make fun of
Americans for being like so stupid.
You try to name five states from the
United States.
I don't live in here.
I don't give a shit.
I'm used to just label them like normal.
Yeah.
Give us a break here.
I'm,
I'm surprised that lesbian porn is so
predominant.
Yeah,
like everywhere across the sea.
The normal.
We're all friends here.
Apparently.
You just like a Western civilization
thing.
Yeah.
Have I value on lesbians?
I really,
this is big for gay acceptance.
That's not progress.
I don't want to know what he are.
ICKY.
But lesbians sounded,
I know don't match that.
I thought we lived in lesbian.
Is that lesbian?
I thought that was,
I thought I thought this was a map with
names of the places and that is the
country.
Yeah,
that was the bit,
that was good.
It was all a bit,
the big,
big country is the best anymore.
Dan,
can you help me clarify?
So who's in a big deck?
Pakistanian who are these guys?
I think that's Nepal.
Both have little dicks.
Uh,
do you have data on that?
I think the thing,
I think why lesbian porn is so popular
is because men and women,
I think,
sure it's crowd pleasing because dudes
are like,
hey,
that's hot.
And then of course girls will like,
I was like,
I don't want to see dudes.
Honestly.
No,
that's true.
Yeah.
We learned earlier that women don't
enjoy sex.
So do you know that,
I find that interesting that people in
Africa are watching Ebony and then North
Africa Arab world.
I know there are Arab,
but I just think,
you know,
you want to see your own content,
your own peeps.
You want to relate to,
people will say that Hi Eric,
that out.
Oh,
it's great.
But okay.
So I think,
but what is the appeal?
Um,
Zachary in our band.
Do any of you guys watch Hentai?
No,
I'm like you ethan.
Like I checked it out out of curiosity,
but I don't,
I don't find it.
I don't find that arousing man.
It's got be,
yes.
Yeah.
Well Ian is always the odd one out and I
appreciate his honesty.
So,
and tell me what your tire you into to.
That's a negative for me and I'm
offended personally.
Never heard of that animal.
Exactly.
Come on,
be level with us.
Nah,
I'm in the mills.
Are you really?
Wait,
are you really?
And so what,
do you know why you prefer older women
or is that just a preface?
You know,
I don't know.
therapist could help you unpack that
word.
The Mill Fsa.
Well you would fit in in India
apparently.
And we have got to stop.
Hold on that,
that's India.
Any places name with [inaudible] and
then also we've got a,
what do we got here,
Dan?
Is that?
Oh,
that would be polar said.
If a country existed at World War II,
I know what it is because of all the
video games are played.
All of my geography comes from hearts of
iron.
Now will you painting now,
Dan and Ian,
will you,
what kind of porn category do you guys
watch?
While I was going to say,
you know it's interesting,
there's a whole milk thing.
It was sort of an eye opening thing when
I realized that I'm old enough that MILF
porn is just for women my age.
Yeah.
That was kind of like a,
that was the oh shit moment right there.
Oh,
that's real.
Let's see what real.
So are you saying that that the ones who
never moved out of their homes,
I can ask funny.
Yeah,
I know I don't have to go.
I didn't agree with that.
When I look at MILF porn,
I see like old days with fake titties.
You said it earlier.
I mean it kind of runs a range,
but it,
it does seem to mill is almost like late
twenties to forties and 50s.
When you go to a porn site,
do you type MILF?
Are you kind of just rolling?
No,
no,
no.
Can we,
can we consciously seeking it out?
Anal?
I feel like we're not giving anal its
fair share of the spotlight,
but,
but the whole country's do a parent,
I was expecting to see more anal in the
chart.
I saw somebody point out that the,
uh,
in the Mideast there,
um,
the anal block,
if you will,
no block block is the exact,
a territory of the old Persian empire
for some reason.
So there's gotta be some correlation
there.
History buffs,
please hook us up.
Please help us out.
Is that in Germany?
I would see,
um,
well that's funny because all over
Iceland apparently.
Oh yeah.
Iceland is just anal.
Is Italy.
Milfs yes.
Oh yeah,
look at that.
That's a surprise.
You see it.
So then there's that.
And then there's also a lot of weird
stuff like that you can't do with real
people like tentacle rec rape.
And it's just I,
it's just so bizarre.
But I think a lot of it's got to be
hardwired from kids watching cause
there's some bomb ass cartoon characters
like Kyla kill
the enemy killed walking like that,
straight up Hentai and those girls are
fucking slamming dude.
Well that's it.
But I never watched antimony kids adult
only as an adult I've seen that shit.
But if I watched that as a kid I
would've been like Dick out all day.
That would awards my fucking mind.
You know what I mean?
And that would have like rearranged all
my sexual desire like an early,
if you introduced that shit at an early
age,
cause like a lot of anime as you said,
it's hypersexualized in one way or
another.
When we were growing up,
we had misty from pokemon.
That's it.
I'll give you that,
I'll give you that.
Or April from April,
April and like hurdles but some cartoon
characters,
the way they draw them with like black,
I'm like daddy's everywhere and nowhere
and then like,
and then the camera's always from the
back.
You're looking at Lek,
her badge and I'll bump stops and it's
too sexy.
Which color?
I think they're hardwired that way.
Option on there talking.
No,
I'm looking for,
I'm looking for furry.
Furry.
Is that a porn category?
Hell yeah.
He's here about life.
I guess so.
You're right.
You guys have a porn preference?
Um,
I type in porn and then I have like
everything available and then depending
on my mood,
my drunkenness level,
uh,
I just go,
yeah,
that one and see what looks good.
What do you usually,
then I go back to reading the Wall
Street Journal.
That's what I come,
you know,
go ahead Jack.
I asked the bus.
Uh,
no.
Um,
you know,
there's a whole trope,
um,
embarrassed,
nude female.
Enf that's like a whole site on reddit
where it's like,
yeah,
yes,
yes.
There's a subreddit.
What is it called?
Embarrassed,
happy and bay.
It's,
I don't know the sub Reddit,
I don't know that one.
But there are so unpack,
unpack that.
There's nothing to back,
it's just,
it's,
it's just like,
like a bullet bourbon.
No.
It's just like God help you through
this.
And Yeah.
Thank,
you know,
embarrassed,
new,
famous females.
This is exactly what it sounds like.
It's like a whole some cute,
it's a whole genre.
It's like,
oops.
You know,
like that kind of shit.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Like,
because as a young kid you saw the
Marilyn Manson,
Marilyn Manson.
Oh yeah.
He certainly got really twisted.
Shall lie.
That's,
that's,
you know,
Marilyn Monroe tow this car like a pinup
trope.
Right.
I'm being embarrassed.
Look old.
Pinups a pinup girl.
The whole embarrassing,
right?
Yeah.
That's a big part of it.
I'm sure you know.
Very retro.
Yeah.
So I'm an old school.
He's old school.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They are MILF snow.
Well,
no,
they're,
they're dead.
They're gum mills.
That's a,
uh,
that's a corpse.
I was like the fuck am I all right.
Kill,
kill,
kill for that.
Like,
I'd like to kill a few baby.
Yeah.
See I,
I'll have,
yeah,
whatever the Corp side.
All right.
Well,
there you have it.
Oh,
this was a fun little,
um,
little excursion,
wasn't it?
Fun Rabbit hole to dive into.
People like kid,
I fucking,
I fucking jerk off.
Did you?
Yeah.
I don't want to hurt anybody.
It's just what Taneesha d and You guys
talked about like,
just like not that different,
I think furry stuff.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah,
because I,
yeah,
I find the furry thing,
it's just strange and wild too,
because apparently they have a flop for
the deck.
We made it up doing no,
I think that's real.
Yeah.
Oh,
we didn't make that up.
You guys didn't see all of the correct,
the record emails that I received last
week.
Furries are pissed.
Yeah.
Not even Piss,
but they're like,
there's a lot more to it.
I see.
I will have to know that we do it.
They don't share their reduced to being
year first and then they're like,
that's not it.
There's much more than you thing.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Oh,
I'm so glad you asked that you left.
Uh,
no,
that's,
that's your thing is why am I the
fucking authority?
I'm just shit you effing
is.
Um,
when furry stop sacks,
you keep saying say that,
but you don't,
don't worry.
I got you.
The first thing is when parties have
sex,
you know it's all a lot of people in the
costume.
The costume I think,
I think it's called sex.
I think I knew about gifting before I
knew it was like this is more out of the
costume you things in what's the point?
Flap out ride or die baby cause they
ain't got a flap on their constant
because they're not like a joint.
Yeah.
How often do they fuck take a mouse hole
for your Dick?
I absolutely got it.
Maybe the gift
part of the,
the the role play,
you know for sure or sexual like that.
Cause like I have a number of viewers,
a number of my,
my,
my viewers are in fact for you and you
can tell by [inaudible] on twitter and
if,
you know,
if it's an Avatar cars to ethan based on
the email and I don't,
I don't doubt it.
I don't discriminate.
I take everybody views desperately just
guys watch the game or awards at all.
Like a few days ago go.
I think the guy who won Gamer of the
year,
it showed up in a costume.
He was a furry and he came out and just
very costume and he accepted it.
And how is being a furry con like how in
the 90s people were like,
it's okay to be gay.
Are we taking it that far?
I don't think so.
I don't think it's that,
are they looking for acceptance or
they'll looking for recognition but,
but why is it that serious don't take
themselves that seriously?
Well Dan,
you've got emails.
Where are they serious or not?
They weren't,
honestly,
they weren't really that mad.
It was more just like,
hey,
just want to let you know it's not
always a sexual thing,
blah blah blah.
So like,
you know,
they were just sort of expanding on it
as far as like my viewers,
like you know when I get tweets and
stuff from people you can see by their
profile picture that like,
you know,
it's them in a furry thing.
Yes.
And I,
I've never met a mean one yet,
so I'm,
I'm prone to like them.
They are very great community.
It's cool though,
dammit.
Why you guys being all nice and I look
like a cynical asshole.
You know,
I have a whole list of hateful things.
I always look like the asshole one
fucking time indigenous peoples today.
Um,
but I did ask this question when
tenacious d was here,
if they are,
they're really into the role playing so
they must paint their dick red.
I'm sorry.
Who's the worries?
Cause we like a dog bone or like dog
boner.
Like it goes red,
the red rocket kind of thing.
Because if you just pay it,
take out a human dick,
that ain't right.
I don't think so.
I don't think that's,
that's a a very amusing thought.
Trust me.
Just,
I don't think they'd take it to that
level.
What would have,
correct me if I'm wrong for who?
Yeah.
But I don't think they go that like
that's,
that's pretty,
uh,
that's a method like that.
Some Daniel Day Lewis Shit right there.
That's some real Marlon Brando Shit.
What about animals with really strange
penis?
Little ducks.
Ducks?
Yeah.
So they probably mutilate their penis.
You just need a little spirit gum.
And a big,
uh,
you know,
they sounds prop.
We need a furry,
plenty of shops,
you know,
watch the firies in la tech art email,
Dan podcast.
Say Shoes.
You productions.com.
Let's get a furry here in costume.
I've got 'em hundred and one questions
where you could do half in and half out.
Go.
Also,
I love my preference also or I want,
I want one who was also acquainted with
the sexual aspect because I do want to,
I want that.
I want to know if they paint their Dick
reade.
You should have one nonsexual furry.
Just does it for the cause playing and
then one who like,
dude,
that's the future of this podcast.
You look at Joe Rogan.
Oh,
let me get a scientists on about sleep.
No,
for,
what the fuck are you?
Hey,
you're welcome.
By the way,
up to the,
the furry train.
Well I know I'm not caught up,
but I just,
I never thought of actually getting one
in here.
I've already had a like a,
an arc.
You was my life on the Internet where
like when I first learned about furries,
I was like,
that's weird.
I hate it.
And then it evolved into like,
oh,
there's just nothing wrong with these
fucking people at all.
Right.
Have you had a good time,
a comment,
etiquette video on furries?
I don't think so.
People have given them such a hard time
on the Internet.
Like I feel like it'd be targeted.
I don't want to be lumped in with the
demeanor side.
I hear that's a guy.
No,
I agree.
I think they'd have it honestly though
in my experience,
they have a very good sense of humor
about it.
If you did it tastefully,
do you do do stuff tastefully comedic
wise I think.
No,
no you didn't.
You I think,
I think you could get away with it
honestly and it'd be very funny and
they're like,
yeah,
if I did well,
I'm just perplexed.
I would never be able to beef for views.
I just,
I just am.
And their costumes are so weird.
Like,
like the familiar face.
It's just,
it's strange.
What's weird about it,
Ethan?
Well,
they all look like a fucking acid trip.
Like humanoid.
Fuck.
Like it's just weird.
I don't know.
Let's get it.
Let's move on.
We're like an hour a furry.
If there was like an outside group
called the scally's alien.
Yeah,
they were all reptilians don't need that
conspiracy theory.
I have to have for,
but then do they put the scales a
little?
Uh,
no.
I would just be like all covered in
turtle shell.
I like it.
Like Thai.
They do seem like they have a creepy
face.
Do you guys all say that's what I'm
saying?
There's a creepy fails.
This next video that's a little black
man.
That's something that that of a person
wearing
that this is some strange outset of
furries.
They did perspective.
That dude who's recording this video
calls him little homie.
So he's a little homey.
I think that's how they prefer it to be
like we men kind of thing.
He just says a little homemade.
He doesn't know him.
Oh,
okay.
One thing at a time.
So we're looking at furry.
The faces is creeps me out.
And I'm sorry if that offends you.
I just divides into the group of people
that has creeped out by it.
His face.
Oh,
I didn't mean to click well there you
have it anyway.
Right.
But look at that.
All hotel guests should behave like
these furries.
Furries are like pinnacle politeness or
you look at your chest man,
you've got a furry your that's your
Caribbean.
I sure am defending them a lot.
I guess it makes you wonder.
It makes you wonder.
No,
I personally am not.
But like,
it's just,
oh,
but do you guys find their faith creepy?
I don't find the face cream if I'm being
honest.
I mean I,
I'll say this,
I don't get it.
I don't get the appeal.
I do not,
I don't find them creepy.
Wow.
I don't find him creepy.
And I like,
I don't want to like,
I don't want to make fun of them cause I
feel,
I feel like a whole community and it's
just like I got none of them.
Likewise.
What's there to get mad at?
Beautifully put.
Beautifully.
I'm pissed.
Oh No.
And all of this dancing.
My eyeline right now that need to be in
my line.
They didn't see the furries or anything.
Oh No.
Well,
we'll talk about what they were
anthropomorphic.
Alright,
we're trouble shooting.
Like what?
What else do you need to know?
Foxes and dogs and whatnot.
Like you've seen furries.
You know what it looks like.
You got it.
You know what if that was like the only
way I could get off,
I mean,
I guess it's not a sex thing,
but if that was the only way I could get
off,
I would be the best for you in the
world.
I would have the dopest shit I would
like.
What's your first SONA?
Jack,
you're a fucking first be a rabbit.
If fucking rabbit implants put into my,
uh,
into my legs so I could hop like one,
like hydraulics and stuff.
If I wasn't liking the action around me,
I would just leap out of that way.
Great icebreaker and also great
conversation ender.
And it's how the end of the night just
leaped into the ceiling above my bed.
I don't have to watch Netflix,
go to bed and turnin knock yourself out.
We called concussion and ready if,
I don't know why,
but um,
you split that,
that clip up into multiple smaller
clips.
I'll tell you when you're watching.
People are so tired of hearing that the
cable,
I can't pull that up here.
I've gotten to watch red letter media at
all.
Their latest video is a god.
What was it about what they do?
It's as if I,
if you know that,
and you know that they do a series
called best of the worst where they just
reviewed terrible forgotten vhs films of
the eighties and nineties.
So I'll spoil the surprise cause it
happened so quickly.
Um,
everything's going fine.
You know,
they do like the little plink Kedo or
Plinko thing of like selecting the
movies.
They,
the drop a ball and the whole grid and
like lands on a vhs tape.
Sometimes it lands on player's choice,
which means that they can choose
whatever video they want.
So Atlanta and player's choice out walks
in fucking macaulay culkin.
We're back.
Any holds up a copy of home alone for,
and he's like,
we're watching this guy.
Wow.
And they,
so they actually watch home alone for
Macaulay Culkin and they're all making
jokes at everyone's extent and it's so
damn funny and it's so like wholesome.
Oh,
how cool is that?
I got the Culkin they got,
they got Kevin mcallister,
I think that's his name,
right.
And I'm like,
well does he live fucking know what I
mean?
No,
he's Macaulay Culkin,
but the animal alone.
Oh,
he's Kevin,
right?
He's Kevin.
He's a little like random when la their
videos.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I think,
I think he's a big fan of red letter
media and red letter media is strangely
like,
okay.
They're like,
yeah,
I think everyone's secretly a big fan of
it's on youtube.
Why?
Secretly?
Because their channels rela I mean this
is not small but relatively smaller than
how well known they are.
Genius.
And they have like that and shit.
The word,
they have their own equity.
Yes they do.
They have,
they have less than 900,000
subscribers are going to get to a
million by the end of the year.
Like if someone pushes for them because
they deserve 10 minute Shum Dick Jokes
next to my bed head more subscribers
than them.
And I was like this,
just like,
it's not fair.
This is a government plot to be fair.
I love your Dick Jokes,
but like red letter media even more.
I know they should have better media
tube and you want to watch it because
they're not like the way I viewed them.
They're not even a youtube channel.
I feel like they ascended beyond a
youtube channel because they don't do
the whole like,
hey,
what's everybody was going on in today?
Like they just go in there like,
well Mike Walter,
hey washing.
I'm apathy.
They're very classy.
But what's so funny?
So,
so dry.
Funny.
We're the fuck did they get their
warehouse is what I want to know.
Red Letter media.
Where did you get this God damn
warehouse and I'll move there.
If this is holly all the time.
What I wonder is if our,
are they furries?
Oh,
you know they are rich Evans might be
like a hedgehog or I believe I fucking
love this is a sonic the hedgehog.
Right.
So this video,
um,
I assume that this little homeys on some
kind of drug.
Hmm.
Cause he seems high on [inaudible].
He seems high energy.
Okay.
But I'll let you guys enjoy is the high
end good vibes.
Good vibes.
Only.
Yeah.
He's not associated.
He's not associated with the guy who
hooked to their mark.
By the way.
I will say he's free.
He's dressed fresh as hell for having to
shop like kids.
Shit.
Like that's a pretty fresh outfit.
He's got the Jordans on Jordan beanies,
got sloppy.
Knows what's up.
Yeah.
He looks good but not as,
he's not having a good day.
I got no audio.
Nope.
Oh Ma.
I got it.
It's okay.
I can,
I can read lips.
Yeah,
no idea what he's saying.
Why furries forever furries together.
Do you get that pre son?
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
I see.
Gotcha.
Trying to rob,
but he doesn't have a weapon or oh
that's not going to work.
You need a weapon piece,
throwing gummy treats at the cashier.
He's trying to steal.
He's St fill that bag up.
I don't even see the bag.
You already gave it to him.
I go,
oh,
that's filled that bag up.
Honestly,
I got to let them all at one point
you'll hear they offer 50 to go away.
Take this.
You go left back.
I just gathered around of course only
throwing gummy treats like what does
that go?
That bad guy.
This is the most gangster shit I ever
seen him drink and what these people are
amazing.
The police coming,
the police coming home avenue here.
This is the alternate ending.
They actually,
Oh yeah,
I get it.
How you're going to say it took me a
second.
I was going to make a bunch of nerdy.
I was going to say this is an alternate.
I'm kingdom hearts three and
coming in January.
I would love to have for him to be a
playable character.
Why?
He has a whole arc and everything.
Okay.
No,
that bag up homie.
Perfectly.
His weapon.
It's gummy gummy.
Holly's coming.
Come on dude.
He's a convenience store.
It gets cluttered.
The bleeds job take down of all time.
I love how the police are just like,
all right,
little.
That'd be like if shawshank redemption
had a bad ending,
we got her with Washington's going to
get away with it.
Thank ain't no.
I think
ultimately this is a tragic video
because this is a guy,
the soul of a gangster and the body of a
child and even those recording him who
are trying to root them on a help and
can't help but laugh as he's Gentili
laid down by the police.
A little slap sticky.
It literally is like some physical
comedy.
Slapstick was,
I think he was on something.
He didn't choke half a beer and then,
but he matched,
obliterated on the ground.
That was amazing.
That's got to be just finishing though.
Like if I worked for the mortal Kombat
game,
I'd be getting in touch with this guy's
people growing wine bottle only bear
smash brothers.
Ultimate has dlc coming out.
Just some food for [inaudible].
Right.
By the way,
that games freaking awesome.
Yeah.
It's all I want.
That's all I want to be doing.
Disgusting.
Sexist brain.
Didn't label you don't play any games,
but I like this one.
It's fun.
Don't get yourself a switch by plea
played smash brothers was in college.
Yeah,
me too.
Game Cube.
I wasn't the,
I walk into a room and it was like the
liveliest thing I've ever seen and I was
like,
God,
I,
I was good at this
one while I used to be real good,
but now I suck at Mineola on the same
level,
which is fun.
But the single player is like amazing.
It's usually,
it takes like four hours on the single
player.
Yeah.
But it's got really fun.
Interesting upgrades and spirits and all
the levels have different difficulties
and different special conditions and
it's really surprising.
It's really fun.
And you have to play to unlock fighters.
And I was like,
fill that bag.
What Dan?
Who's your,
uh,
what's your meaning?
We've been playing a lot of Falcon,
but just,
just what's available to me.
Yeah.
Kirby's what's up?
Kirby Darby all day.
Herbie really knows how to fill that
bag.
[inaudible]
that's a great,
great sound bite.
So I'm just kind of like,
I am overwhelmed because I grew up on
the end 64 version of Spanish.
When you unlock everything,
there are 12 fucking character.
I know,
I know.
And then this new game there's over 70
low and the the amount of level fucking
levels there were 900 plus.
It's the offering.
The pump had your,
I'm a nerd.
Like I grew up on the end like even
more.
I never had a game cube so I never
played melee and cubes.
Awesome.
I went right from [inaudible] 64 to weep
so I never had an inbetween.
I know the game cube is a great system,
but like I grew up on the,
on the laggy slow and 64 version.
Like if there were too many characters
and smashing and 64 it would slow it
down.
It would turn into like a powerpoint
presentation and 15 frames a second and
now we're at the sway and play in
handheld moments.
It's,
it's,
it's just so fun party over last weekend
and we just like play it.
I'm not characters.
Have you played online yet?
Because I haven't tried online yet.
I only just bought,
you know,
it's funny cause I now you have to buy
online.
Like if the,
which I hate so I just did that the
other day to play one of my buds.
Um,
I haven't tried it yet though.
But the online it has a good offer
because you get to play all the retro
games.
You get to stream them.
Like what are some,
what are some examples of French?
Okay Mario three you get to play like
original Gallica you get to play it.
There's like a lot of really retro
fricking cool ass games all stope that's
a huge part.
I think they keep adding all the classic
shit there.
That's what they need to do with the
virtual console.
That's what the wheat and the wheat you
had going for it.
They need like more classic [inaudible]
16 but,
and I think they're doing that so it's
really cool.
That's smart.
Fill that bag up with new games.
Here's the Gosh,
can you go,
here's a,
here's a neuro.
We got a new story.
We got so many scoops.
Story.
Armored trucks spells cash on Jersey
highway drivers pull over on the freeway
and rushed to grab dollar bills.
[inaudible] I hope that someone fill it
back up.
So,
uh,
a brinks truck.
I guess the back just sprung open and
like 20 hate when that are just all over
the freeway.
It's quite as something.
Um,
now what would cause that to happen?
Like was it triggered to open up to
spring open or it was just a mechanical
malfunction.
It was in an accident.
And actually I've got a guy,
by the way,
this poor son of a gun on the freeway
picking up dollar bills.
That's the brinks guy trying to save his
job.
Ooh.
Are you serious?
Yeah,
he's at now when people realize those
are dollar bills flying around and not
garbage,
I will start pulling over to pick them
up for the,
for the workers or the poor,
like anyone that has to collect that
just a salvage their fucking right.
That's the brinks guide thing.
Well he's having a good time.
Hey,
here you go man.
And brings you form is seen here.
Trying to collect the money thing is
hilarious.
Like,
what the fuck else am I going to do?
Uh,
that's scary.
I mean like you can't just hop out of
here.
He can't pull over and just hop out of
your day,
do frogger it,
you know,
they got this guy,
he's like,
oh,
there's no way.
Right.
Yeah.
This was the perfect situation for a
little homie though.
He would have filled a lot.
Sit them out like a Roomba.
Oh wait,
no,
that's accurate.
No,
I think you're right.
that holds the whole fine.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I'll take it.
Can we get an answer?
Is that fine?
Judges?
That's not an,
that'd be fair craft.
I don't think you're going to pick up
enough dollar bills paid for that.
No,
this is New Jersey,
so all those accidents,
we're going to happen anyway.
Whether or not during that turnpike gets
you,
Amanda.
The Nj Turnpike,
I've driven it many a time.
There's a lot of dollars,
baby,
their 20s,
all of them.
That's one thing.
That's the thing.
They're Japanese,
so it's like,
I don't know if I'm working like minimum
wage,
I'm pulling over and grabbing onto this
dude.
I can be Mark Walberg.
I'd pull over and grab five 27 30 that's
true.
I'm mark Walberg.
I'm pulling over.
I'm punching a Chinese man face and
blinding him.
Print.
It might cry or chamber.
Ethan.
I,
I received a message that he may not
have blinded the man.
He the mind.
The man was already blind.
He punched her and going,
man.
Oh,
what a fucking loser.
I heard he was blinded him and one,
I suspect he was missing an eye.
He was like an eye know.
Can we pull out,
can you look it up on wikipedia?
Because I want him to get the facts
straight on this.
Should we ask Mark Walberg I want to
know what happened.
What can we do?
We'd have them all time.
Everybody held.
No,
no,
no.
Don't do that.
I don't want to start trouble with mark.
I mean tweeted after your hand.
It was a great movie.
I love,
love it.
Acting.
Mark.
I love you're acting.
You're a cool guy.
I left that whole shtick.
I want some kids.
Yeah.
I think I'm really into this,
you know,
three kids that said he seemed like a
happy guy.
He'll see that part.
Then they fall asleep cause it's like
he's not gonna be able to make it
through the whole podcast pass out.
I have a feeling he's going to let show
up like he's like smoking from his cryo
treatment on the door.
He's like piece of dry ice.
I heard you were talking shit,
that's not cool,
man.
I been working out for three hours
today.
I'm interrupted my family time for this.
Okay,
right.
Drag my kids along.
Now they're going to beat you up.
Now I'm gonna throw down.
Okay.
And I don't want to do this.
I don't want to do this.
I'm a sweet guy,
you know?
But you forced me to do this.
Look,
I changed.
I can't open if that Chinese man had a
week.
I don't blind people anymore.
No,
I'm no expert.
But a great idea for a podcast is just
three guys doing mark Walberg and
practice to an hour.
That's all it is.
Walberg welcome to the Walberg podcast.
Okay,
we're going to talk about the civil war.
Don't know how it started.
How it ended though would be nice to be
nice to black people.
Is it that hard?
I mean,
Hey,
I think treat everyone with respect.
Am I right guys?
All right.
That was the podcast.
Thanks for [inaudible].
I mean black people or people.
Okay.
I mean,
what's so hard to understand about that?
Lincoln died for it again.
Ah,
I like that.
That's gold.
Absolutely.
And can we get an update on the Maher?
The Walberg we get him to sign a
release.
Yeah.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to find a good source on it.
And uh,
the story is kind of weird.
It definitely artists and Martin,
a impression of Mark Wahlberg.
Yeah.
I can't,
I a new kids on the block reunion from
my,
uh,
what,
what was it?
I keep on my calvins to stop the age
from getting it.
[inaudible] story for a long time was
that he blinded him.
However,
I see an article where they interviewed
the guy that got beaten up and he claims
he was already blind in one eye.
And so that was a kind of a miss
communication.
But the source on this is the daily
mail,
which is garbage.
So who knows that guy?
He was already blind.
Hey,
can,
can I,
can I just quickly shout out my wife
Erin because she shits on the Daily Mail
every day on our story and it's
hilarious.
Like she'll screencap stories and then
just write in her like own captions
like,
um,
it's,
it's incredible if you want to it on the
day you sent me your Aa newspapers,
I was like a tab and we not find more
legitimate information cause I'm very
good.
Okay,
well great.
It's already blind was this story
because I'm talked out,
I was trying to punch it back in.
I was helping him out.
Okay.
Wouldn't go in the first time.
Yeah,
you're a lot of Thompson flood.
I was going to run out of power.
Let me help you.
I have another very important update on
the furry penis question God.
And somebody has emailed,
hi Dan.
Watching podcasts right now.
Furries don't paint their pains but,
but there is a website called bad dragon
that has quote wearables,
which are toys you can put on your pain
into making it look like an animal.
Get my shape of water.
I guess my question is how prevalent are
these toys and the furry community?
Uh,
he does not.
He's not clarified but enough to support
a,
a vibrant economy.
And right now what?
Now again,
so you're talking about having a sex act
where your penis doesn't even you cause
he's,
it's a wearable stirrup on,
I mean people,
people do that.
Well if you have a dick do you strap on?
If you want it to look like a duck's
corkscrew cock.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So does your Dick,
I'm just weird.
So does it go over your erect penis or
you floss it?
Dan,
that's a good question.
Hey,
the website's called bad dragon.
Feel free to pull it away this month.
The circuitry to one to one match your
pee.
We don't even have that in vr yet.
That's true that,
that'd be the next one.
PSVR too.
I got a question for you guys.
Is fucking a sex robot cheating?
Fuck,
that's a tough one.
That's a tough one because I know that
sounds like that kind of thing.
We're,
while I'm fucking a sexual would,
I'd be like,
this ain't cheating.
I'm going to say no.
I'm going to say,
I'll be bald and just take a stance and
say no because it's a fucking robot.
I don't think it's at what point when
you have like super advanced,
like let's say it's got like a
personality and it fucking sucks and
swirls on your Dick,
like no human can and you're like,
you know what?
I'm going to go take off baby.
I'll be back.
Um,
I'm just going to go hang out and I'll
be back.
You Go,
you fuck,
you have the best.
You fuck your robot.
I don't think it's cheating because it's
a rope.
Yeah.
I will say,
I'm like,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to be bullied because,
so do you think eric would be upset if
she knew that you were decking out to
fuck a,
hey,
I got your back on masturbation.
That's all it is.
Is it a very interesting,
it depends on the kind of robot and like
if it's in a westward where they're all,
that's the ultimate in a westworld robot
isn't cheating.
No,
I don't think so.
Ah,
you know what's funny,
Aaron and I have talked about this,
she's like,
Oh,
you've fleshed out Luli go to town on
some hot robot.
We talked,
you guys,
have you guys have an agreement,
an agreement until that robot says,
um,
so what are we,
I will fucking label on it.
Yeah,
that's what I turn it off.
That's when he reached around and you
started complaining about,
I agree.
The robots like,
well,
you know,
you're going to get rid of it.
You're happier with me.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I didn't think it,
I don't want elog off getting some like
fucking insane robot cock like 10 inch
fucking robot,
insane cock.
But it's purely Tori.
No Web apps.
He's jacked.
He's fucking handsome.
Averagely hung the robot.
Not a big deal.
That's fine.
But if why,
if you go and hang out with the robot,
starts spending time.
Okay.
That's when it gets a little weird when
you're like,
when you're not fucking the robot you
mean?
Or just like plain smashed with Mike.
He's opening a door and like the robot.
All right.
Get Out.
It's like the printer in your bedroom
that you have to keep them plugged a
westward.
Susan one before they found out a data
lake world loophole.
I'm going to spoil it.
So if you haven't watched Westworld,
just skip for the next 30 seconds.
Yeah,
you guys have all seen it.
Yeah.
So when they're in there,
they are scanning their brain to like
clone them or they're making like
personality types.
They're all fucking robots.
They can just collect the semen and
cloned them there.
Cause this like a huge seed bank that's
all westward as a huge semen bank.
I think the humans just get a bunch of
seen it.
But you're not going to like,
I don't know what you'd do with it.
You just get semen though.
Get a bunch of semen dude.
That's all I know.
That would be really funny if
westworld's big request was like,
hey you have 30 kids we've been
collected.
There are real people and they're your
kids cause we have so much sema we don't
know what to do with at all.
We just have buckets of semen.
It we save it all tested.
We save all of it.
There's like a volt,
you know they're like the vault with
everyone's brain.
It's backed up.
It's just,
what if it was just as big a swimming
pool of Siemens.
This is a all of our guests.
What is this the ball to come?
We're going to see what that does and
you're giving the writers too many
ideas.
You guys,
you got to lock it up.
Okay.
You guys can come back.
Spoilers over just a bunch of semen.
No split season two and I am not
spoiling it off.
Well I gave away the plot a little bit.
A little bit too convoluted like to me,
like I saw season one and it was fun and
then like I heard I didn't even start
season two.
I just heard all these rumors and I
liked it.
Really.
I just heard too many people going like,
what the fuck?
I love.
Well it's not like I got anything better
to watch.
I can't watch thrones.
Yeah.
I like getting extremely high and
watching like a handful of shows in
westworld is one of them because I,
I kind of don't give a shit what
happens.
I'm not going to get mad.
Whatever they do,
I'm just going to be like,
all right,
that's where you're going.
How do you
normally get mad?
Why?
I'm used this fucking ride.
I feel like I would get a panic attack
trying to watch it high because it's
already so hard to follow.
Like what's going on?
I get panic attacks high anytime,
so yeah,
I don't have to watch any better sex.
I've never rewatch episodes of a TV show
so many times just to understand what
happened.
It's so complicated.
I don't,
that's what turns me off.
It's like being that guy,
that guy.
Wow.
Partly my Iq is to 50 bucks.
Yeah.
What's it like on your,
a little a pedal on us about the soul.
The way that I washed it is like I
assume that you understand what you're
supposed to and whatnot because no,
you're a duck.
Can't try too hard.
[inaudible]
game of thrones to Youtube 50 well,
I read the book which is required.
I've not read that book.
I love game of thrones,
but I'll be damned if there were like
some characters whose names I forget and
when they pop up sometimes it's like
this big revelation of character pops up
and I go,
ah,
fuck who's that again?
Because it's supposed to be this big
dramatic ball.
What's Your Iq?
It's like 300 something,
but like sometimes I can like an asshole
and it's been that guy hitting your
punching bag.
You got to be that guy.
Someone's got an old guy.
Proudly that guy.
I mean we're going to do saying nice
things about what's rule.
I like westworld.
Everyone's complaining about like
inception,
like I had to watch at 20 times.
It's hard about it.
Anyone's complained about at this time.
It's different.
I'm with you on that one because like
people complain about that ending and it
being ambiguous.
It's like wow.
I mean that was the point.
Many movies,
but they're like layers in a,
they're in the Ma to handle it.
It takes like two tries and you get it.
It's like going into more dreams.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's more drinks.
It's entertaining.
Well to be frank,
we do all have at least two 50 Iq.
My Iq is just the letters I in queue,
which could be worse.
I am afraid to take an Iq test.
I cook can't face the reality that I
probably have like a 90.
You're not fucking night.
I think I have.
I don't think because,
well I wrote the book,
grandparent,
you're um,
you're not a 90 sign.
You're a one on one year one.
Oh,
you're award.
No one to me,
even no matter what the doctors tell
you,
barely over the mediocre threshold that
I feel like I'm really bad at like
pattern recognition,
which is like a lot of what the Iq is
really,
you know,
we did that escape room and me and Isla
we're set with the task of doing some
logic puzzle and I'm,
and I'm like I'm the dominant,
we couldn't figure it out.
Well escape rooms are different because
they,
they put you in a time constraint and I
feel like doctors,
they're like social like with strangers.
Mostly strangers.
Yeah.
I mean like friends of friends.
So we didn't know everyone.
Got It.
I learned a lot about myself in the
escape room in that like I'm kind of a
bitch like in a policy way.
Far Away.
Yeah.
It was like,
okay.
So I had the puzzle figured out like I
was on my welfare and believe in myself
that I had it.
I give like a broad stroke here.
Like there were a bunch of books
sensitive genius.
The way that you set the books up is,
is the trick because there was like a,
you used the flashlight and it's a black
light and you run it along the books and
it tells you the combination for the
safe.
So I'm over here playing with these
fucking books,
like,
oh,
maybe they should be like this,
maybe they should be like this.
And I was starting to get there and then
someone else,
someone came over this,
the,
the like Alpha male of the group who I
didn't know it was me.
Where are you wearing your soil boys?
Only on the inner side.
Uh,
and then I was just playing with them
and I was like,
yeah,
you give it a try,
man.
It's just completely had it figured out.
I was probably three minutes away from
figuring out that I only know that
because this other guy came over,
fuck them all up,
didn't know what he was doing and walked
away.
And then the,
there was a,
uh,
an actor in the room.
So there was someone who was like
chained to the bed.
It was like a Zombie or something like
that in a while.
And she was like,
you know,
like the rules were don't get near this
person,
don't touch them.
Which means that someone's touched them
before.
There's no,
I'm sure that it's a rule because
someone did it right.
Ah,
and she just like,
I could see her break character and get
exasperated and she walked over,
redid everything I did and set it up,
yelled at it like not with words,
just went and then like left the way.
And so I was like,
hey,
so what,
she solved it.
She solved it.
But she did what I did because you
didn't have the,
the audacity,
the courage.
Oh I heard was her calling me a pussy.
That's right.
No,
that's got to fuck with you,
man.
That's got to fuck if you're with me a
little bit.
Cause I was like,
I was right about that.
The confidence for the rest of it.
I tried to take the initiative and I was
wrong to every other,
all the other,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm the fucking genius at this.
I got that to fifth.
It's just that one aspect that you were
right.
Think the one thing.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't like this came from,
I don't like the social situation.
I don't like the social pressure.
I am not alpha,
I'm not outgoing and I'm not smart.
So all those combined,
not a good time.
All those combine trapped in a little
room.
I think you need to be with the right
people.
Like a flashback to middle school.
It's like doing,
I hear that.
I hear you.
I was not good at those tests Jack.
Yeah,
Mike is,
they used to give us logic tests and
middle school and all these fucking
nerds would like,
they'll like if Beth had 12 cherries and
George punched her in the pussy and she
dropped to exactly what,
they're obviously,
well regardless,
but I was not good at these and there
was like the really dumb people.
They,
I beat them but that wasn't a feed but I
was not head of the pack.
I honestly think if you're with like a
group of people I know and like you like
you're cool with it.
They're not friends of friends of
friends are not like friends three times
removed.
These are you get home,
you're going to have a good fucking
time.
I'm going to say I suck at a room
escapes.
I've done a number of them.
Have you?
Yeah,
but I have a good time cause I'm with
like people I trust and I know and I
light.
Yeah.
And it makes the,
hold on.
Let me ask you this.
Have you ever been like with your
friends in an escape room?
Cause he's done a lot.
Have you ever looked at one of your
friends and said yourself,
damn,
that guy's fucking dumb.
Yes I have.
I have definitely once.
You don't have to say who,
but what was the situation?
I'll give you his twitter handle and
everything.
No,
no,
no.
It was just,
it was just like,
oh,
I'm so dumb that I didn't realize I was
doing escape room side of me to play it
on the bus.
But yeah,
it was absolutely.
That's hilarious.
No bad dude.
It was,
um,
no,
it was like,
I don't know the exact example.
It was just like pieces drawn together.
I was wondering what the Hell is going
on?
Your hair is popping on the top.
I was like,
that's amazing.
Fill that bag.
That bag of pills.
Um,
no.
It was just like the guy was clearly
clueless or girl,
let's not discriminate.
Could have been anyone.
Could been anyone.
There's dude.
Yeah it was a guy.
He or she was just like so clueless
about like just everything.
They didn't really get it,
but like it did.
I didn't think less of the person,
cause I already knew that going in.
I was like,
I already know this.
I know you're dead weight though.
I'm dead weight.
It's so,
it was just kinda like it.
But it was fun.
Like we just had a good,
so I felt like dead weight.
I did not accomplish anything.
That's fair.
But there were so many people that it
was kind of a fun,
my wife did all the caring.
Aaron did all the caring and,
and all the caring and the caring,
the caring and caring.
But like,
and you know,
I was like,
I one I kind of felt like dead weight
too.
But on the other hand I was a little
proud,
but I still had fun cause I was like
just with my guys just going like,
I think this goes here.
Oh fuck or no,
I don't know.
I think you have to be in the right
frame of mind.
But I mean also,
you know,
if you don't like escape rooms,
you don't like escape room.
We should do an escape room together
with friends that you trust.
Like,
like not less friends with friends with
her.
Wow.
No,
I would,
are you kidding?
I would love to and I suck at escape
rooms.
I'm not going to be the guy.
It's like,
Oh,
I've done it now.
It's like set up some fucking cameras in
and getting nothing done.
I think that's fine.
We'll have a game broadcast that to the
world.
Cause I'll look like a fucking,
just do it.
Oh me,
I said,
Eric,
I want to broadcast it.
Get out of the dreaming mind set for one
fucking charity.
It's always for Sarah Cherry.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Me though.
Um,
the charity by charity,
bitch.
Yeah.
Right.
Uh,
Eric's,
Eric's happy ferris kids.
That's great.
What's the name of the charity?
Eric sick kids.
Did you make them sick?
Are there,
I don't have to answer that.
Ethan.
Mark man kids.
I love that.
They're my kids and they're sick.
All right.
We need help.
What else do you need to know?
Yeah,
right.
They're really sick,
dude.
Mind your own business.
What's wrong with them?
I don't have to answer that.
Can I get 10 bucks please?
Um,
we have watched on the show before a
compilation of celebrities are not
performers falling off stage during
their performance.
And we had an legendary submission from
one of our fans,
Matthew Schelok.
That's a hell of a last name.
Sounds Lachtar Matthew.
So wait,
matthew was a celebrity.
No,
no,
this was the person who submitted it.
Oh,
I'm just celebrity is Gamma Colin
too?
I'm not familiar with,
she's a UK something going on in the UK,
but she would cook a fucking
unbelievable lifetime.
Make me row the UK.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
Oh,
she's like,
it's like a podcast.
Yeah.
So here's gamma.
Colin's taking the tumble of a lifetime
TV show.
Okay,
wow.
Now this gets real.
They can't lift her up a bit on the
heavier side,
the whole game,
the whole game.
But here's what's really funny is this
stage,
the guy who controls the stages,
like trying to help her out and he lifts
the fucking stage up cause they can't
get her up.
Watch this.
There's no hydraulic thing.
Yeah,
I see,
I see.
She took it.
She fell into the hole.
She's getting them.
Good sense of humor about it.
She's like laughing to know she was a
sweetheart.
Yeah.
It's got to be embarrassing that I feel
a little bad for.
That's got a,
she actually does an instant story
here and she's got a lot of charm and
charisma about it.
Those halls in this space who's putting
holes in stages,
we saw a lot of people fall victim to
the fold.
That's not,
she's a superstar
professional.
I just want to let you know I'm alive.
Wembley Stadium,
a tomboy on the stage.
I'm alive guys.
I'm about going back home and we've
reached out and when I believe this
moment down,
Mj,
hell,
British accent.
Never sound
real.
She sounds like she's doing a bitch.
She's a champion man.
She's a chat.
She took a tumble and she took it to
heart,
man.
That's what,
what more can you want?
Good for her.
Oh,
I fell Neil donut.
no stage.
No,
I mean Newell Finn.
Oh God.
Damn.
Oh,
here's another great one.
Speaking of it is another,
oh,
this video had me dying.
This mom who is one of the funniest
things I've seen in a long time,
please don't even tell us anything about
it.
Just play it.
Okay.
Oh,
well that's novel,
Jack.
Come on.
What?
Why don't I just play videos and not say
anything?
Come on.
Don't say a word.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
That's a,
a a a instructor it seems.
Oh No,
I don't even need to know how they do it
in rally races because it's so intense.
It's a team.
There's two people.
One person drives and one person
memorizes the course and tells them how
hard the turns on.
Yeah.
It's always,
it's a two man sports.
No fucking clue.
Just imagine.
So,
do you want me to keep talking,
Jack?
I'm not that fat.
No,
no,
no.
I'm photo maps.
Mayor Kulpa was just a human being in
your passenger seat.
They're like 0.3.
Why am I doing his accent as the first
time ever heard an accent?
I'm not going to do that.
Oh Hell No.
I need dewalt,
Tommy.
I need to not listen to me for the love
of God.
Well,
you're doing is fine.
Wow.
For the love of God.
Sammy,
he gets so intense.
Please send me,
I'm begging you.
You'll have to listen to me.
By the way,
you owe $2,000
to the irs.
Sammy.
Listen,
the irs,
you're going to a rescue.
Semi blue.
Grama must pay me 10,000
okay.
I thought that it's from like Africa.
Usually those scans to some of them.
I know where they are.
Right?
There's always the Nigerian prince.
Yeah,
it,
that one doesn't hold water anymore.
I know.
I think it's the irs.
No,
listen to me,
Sammy this.
Those are the new thing.
Yeah.
I think that's the new hot,
I need that southern gentleman and
converted.
Listen to me grandma.
I will fuck you.
They're seeing those on youtube seen
though at the end hair to like fuck it.
I go for all of those guys.
That's exactly it.
The Boga.
Yeah,
that sounds familiar.
Oh yeah.
He had a folder with like porn.
I knew about the guy like dive in,
but it was like naked mole rats live
once and watched him do it for like a
half hour shit and like I'm just eating
lunch and watching this and I'm like,
this is better than I know is better
than sex.
I said it out loud.
Were you masturbating at that time?
Then the furry on my bed turned and
said,
what better than my bob?
Is it bad dragon Dan?
It was bad.
Yeah.
I think that was my vocabulary.
That bad dragon.
All right,
so listen to me,
Sammy for the love of God.
So usually there
manic.
Usually they work very harmoniously and
their team and it's very intense.
So he's like a left turn sharp 45
degrees.
Yeah,
that's how they work.
So this,
so this is like fascinating.
Can you imagine if Siri was like go,
go,
go.
No,
I don't work well under pressure.
So this is fantastic.
Please follow the road.
I mean honestly he just has to follow
the fucking road really bad.
What are you doing?
That'd be awesome.
Tell me out of drag.
Don't tell me how to literally,
yeah,
literally his job,
he has to be a backseat driver.
Right.
That means bugging you who are breaking
the car.
Don't tell me how to drive.
That is terrifying.
I mean like I'm,
I'm a bad enough driver as it is,
but having a guy like
aggressively screen at me.
Yeah.
I just saw her thumb nail down there.
It's a good thumbnail.
Thank you for updating our picture of
Carl Sagan.
Salvia for,
that's what I noticed too.
Your turtle neck.
Yep.
Absolutely.
So congratulate thanks to you actually
have a song for I like that.
That's all I get.
Is that hot dad was beautiful.
Yes it is hot.
Dad Shut up to the top.
That hot dad,
um,
just got a cassette in the mail from Hot
Dad.
Shut out like a tape cassette.
He's selling a tape cassette.
That's fine.
Called them now.
That's what I call hot dad's music.
Shit.
Fucking genius.
He's a genius.
And how was it?
Did you find anything to play it off?
I've still got into the plastic wrap,
but in my car I still have a tape deck.
It's going in there.
Where's he based again?
Like,
oh,
I don't,
um,
I don't know if you can disclose that.
I mean like,
yeah,
don't worry about it.
You,
I'm privy.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Because like I asked,
because we gotta get him over so we can
do karaoke and seeing,
um,
I'm in a,
well,
I cannot see that as an issue,
you know what I mean?
So like Noel,
that's all,
it's not a,
it's not,
no.
Well,
breakers did Christmas song.
Oh,
we're talking about the classic a
songwriter x and the skeleton band fell
on a,
well,
I,
that's a whole rabbit hole.
I apologize.
I'm just trying to distracting you guys
from the podcast.
No,
you're not quickly.
I'll get very much.
I,
uh,
I think it is.
Wow.
It is.
So there's this,
uh,
like that's impressive.
Drilled in our brains.
I'm sorry.
So here's a couple of Christian grails.
Girl girl defined this.
Now a lot of Christians,
they wait until marriage to have to have
quite as,
but uh,
we all should as we all should.
As we talked earlier,
abstinence is the only way to prevent
aids counter to what Mark Walberg would
have you believe.
It's not just the Calvin's mark,
sorry.
But in the pursuit of Jesus's love,
they not only waited to have sex,
they waited until marriage to kiss.
Oh yeah,
that sounds right.
Each other or anyone in general married
each other.
So did they go from not even kissing the
two?
Sticking it in.
Okay,
so I'm reading the waiting until
marriage to kiss isn't something you'll
hear much about from pop culture.
Although saving sex,
kissing,
or any other intimate act for marriage
is a rarity.
It can be done.
So that's what they're claiming to have
done.
Yes.
Interesting.
I can't wait to see these nuts,
sex go.
And today we are going to be talking
about where's this loving that like
dislike ratio.
Very solid.
Very,
very solid.
Yeah.
You to rewind shit right there.
That's a shame.
We'll let,
is there any way we can get them to
kiss?
Because lesbian is the most popular
category.
I do it
most of the world apparently.
Well Russia wait 20 years and they'll
get a kick in in Spain.
Eight years.
Yeah.
I will be on my honeymoon.
I'm not very young.
She's going to get some to deal.
I'm so excited.
So when you watch this I will be doing
all sorts of in and I'm not assuming
that.
I'm so excited.
God's a shame.
I've never heard that term.
I'll be doing all sorts of kissing and
I've never heard that term used on
ironically like she means it.
She like,
she's excited about like being so quote
unquote loose in that,
in that way it's fascinating loose.
You know what I mean?
In her definition,
like I'll be like she's saying I'm not
ashamed to admit it because like yeah,
it's fine.
Only you know.
Yes,
exactly.
Oh,
I can finally,
here's the guy I like kiss.
Interesting girl.
You should have been kissing from the
get go because like we stopped that
video.
No,
no,
no.
We've seen that video.
There's another viral video of like a
couple,
um,
kissing at their,
like they French kiss at their wedding
for the very first time.
You know what I'm talking about that
it's like real bad.
It's like that's why that's why your
kids before you get married dude.
Yeah.
And it's real crane.
Well they're taking it to like the bio.
Like they're like,
listen,
just don't fuck,
but this girls are wearing vr.
But like God,
fuck Jesus mom.
She knows happen.
Yeah,
he raped a big
cause that's,
can I say that our sponsors today?
You're right.
That is true.
Technically on the freaks.
It's like,
it's like they can you
feel scared.
I started to her.
I said,
yeah,
well it's true.
I'm going to be God raped Eric.
Well at this bourbon is just fan.
So much progress.
It's all me and Jack.
How are you guys still fine?
I don't know.
I really fought hard.
Are you guys feeling it's off guys.
Feel good.
We felt it in an hour ago.
I don't mean to speak for you,
but we felt it an hour or two silver.
You know what the problem is?
I'm pregnant.
Yeah.
So I really messed up.
At least you're being honest,
man.
Whew.
Uh,
sweeps week.
Can I tell you what good woody and the
one thing I'm excited for you that'll be
pregnant for it.
Besides that we eat pizza every night.
Fucking my happy place.
Oh yeah.
Is that when she's about your four
months pregnant and about four more
months?
I think we'll be able to,
you'll be able to be on like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
That's like,
you can touch tummies,
touch stomachs.
Oh Dude.
Beach photos.
That's,
yeah,
there you go.
In quite nudes or what pregnancies all
about are you,
I know,
I know you're Jewish,
but your Christmas cards could be
dynamite when you do exactly that.
You just show your,
you just your,
your
healing.
You're like laying like on the top of my
graphs,
your bellies are out so that it looks
like an hourglass.
Oh,
it will be amazing.
Beautiful.
It's really it.
Can I refer to class?
Very excited.
In fact,
we have an ultrasound a Monday.
Well we find the gender for sure.
Even though we think it's a boy.
So you want to,
you want cool.
Cool.
I'm just curious,
has there been like a thing where you
guys know like,
like,
oh,
I can tell.
No,
just in the last ultrasound they said it
looks like it might be a boy.
I wasn't sure.
Are you going to tell the world or keep
it to yourselves when you find out?
And we already,
are you going to have a really cool,
um,
gender announcement where you set
California on fire?
I saw that.
Oh Shit.
Wild Bro.
Slow to pixar is a rich,
it was a reach.
I do have a sketch plan that I've
already said on this shit,
but I'm going to do it.
I'm going to go,
you know how people put it in like
confetti and they shoot like blue or,
yeah.
So I'm going to shoot it and it's going
to be white and I'm gonna look in the
screen and say,
you fucking assumed my baby's gender.
You pigs.
This is sick fucking dare you.
It's just white.
You sit,
get real hostile.
The microphone like how fun.
Israel,
we don't have the baby gender reveal.
They don't have time.
They just ship them out and it feel like
I don't even have time to look at when
the leg onto the next one.
I'll give you a quick run through a
miracle of birth.
They should.
I think it was a boy,
but I'm free.
I'm already eight months pregnant.
She had to do this.
That's how sex that works.
Huh?
You like if you had like weird like food
stuff.
I've always heard about.
I am eating pizza now.
It's so weird.
Oh my God.
Nobody likes,
he's the art of it.
I want to hear some crazy shit,
but she eats a lot of pickles,
which is a weird pickles and peanut
butter.
I Love Lucy style.
Is that what you're going?
Yeah.
You know the one thing that's been
happening to me,
I can go into a rouse like I can't stand
the smell of raw like a really intense
fried chicken smell.
But you were like,
okay.
Beforehand.
Interesting.
It's something heightened like your,
your your sensitivities maybe.
Okay.
But she doesn't want to,
she's never been nauseous.
So I was cooking chicken the other day
and she had a panic attack.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
chicken.
A trigger trigger me in general.
Okay.
Spooks.
You like to live that vegetarian life
for a little bit apparently.
That's fine.
You're in La.
There are worse places to be Vegan or
vegetarian and you can get it.
You gotta fucking Burger with
everything.
But it's very in style.
What time we were in Mexico,
I may have told the story about it.
I just,
it's so funny.
We literally were dying laughing,
right?
A pizza place in Mexico and we ordered
the,
on the menu,
there's a pizza with like,
you know,
Bell Peppers,
black olives,
mushrooms and pepperoni.
And we sell we,
so we say we want this one but no
pepperoni.
And he's like,
oh,
so do you want bacon?
And we're like,
no,
me.
And he's like,
oh,
so do you want steak?
And we're like,
no meat.
He's like,
oh,
so do you want pork?
We're like,
no meat.
Like he couldn't fathom.
It.
Just didn't make,
we thought he was enrolling us.
We started looking at each other and
just laughing because it was getting so
crazy.
What do you mean he couldn't understand?
He thought he was misunderstanding.
Oh my God,
you're throwing bags at him.
I was like,
no,
fucking me dude.
I thought he was fucking with me.
Like get the fucking picture.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
What else?
Is there fun?
Would food?
Um,
like do you guys cook a lot at home or
like order out?
I like it when we cook,
but sometimes we get too busy.
It's a chore.
Yeah.
It's tough.
She's eating a lot.
That's what's up.
Yeah.
And I've gained weight.
There's no question.
I think I've gained like 10 fucking
pounds.
If I'm being honest.
Then you've been pregnant and I'm having
like the craziest shits,
like so much shit.
Like it's crazy.
I'm sorry.
I just want to know.
My shits have been insane and here's
something they don't tell you about
antidepressants that I learned ever
since I started taking those.
My shifts have been a one time.
He's like,
no,
like quality is amazing.
I know it's gross,
but you got to come in and you've got to
look at it.
We'll see.
Right to call you in.
It was fine.
It was like,
well no,
because I'm playing some fucking dude
[inaudible] I always had like diarrhea,
really loose nasty bowel movements and
lots of cleaning issues.
And so my shits are like beautifully
sculpted one way.
Yeah,
like the quality like,
and then I'll be taking like the fatty
shipment to size and tact one piece
intact.
Like guys in my whole forearm.
Like I haven't been having shits like
this since I was like 12.
What's the secret?
Are you,
how are you eating differently or you're
not a monster?
It's the antidepressant,
I guess it,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Metamucil anymore.
And I do take the Metamucil,
but before I started the antidepressant,
my shifts weren't that much better.
Like at least the form.
But then I guess I guess the
antidepressant makes you constipated and
it even me out.
Oh,
that's interesting.
I can shit.
And like you had like an emergency break
sort of thing going on where like beyond
what?
Uh,
what like uh,
someone else.
In a similar situation would need,
maybe they will.
Maybe the negative effect was a
positive,
right?
That's right.
And sometimes I wonder if sometimes I
wonder if the antidepressant works at
all or if I'm just happy all the time
cause my shit just go off the chain.
I get excited every day when I shit
fiber pills,
I swear to God.
Yeah,
group therapy,
they're just straight fiber.
I get excited every day,
every day and I swear to God,
it's the highlight of my day.
It's like because I've been living my
life with this nightmare of shits I've
shits and now it's just like,
hmm.
I come out dancing and celebrate that.
That's,
do you guys have a nice quality bell or
you know,
it's all ebb and flow line with all flow
and no hub.
I got my hills and valleys.
We absolutely,
absolutely.
I was shitting.
I'll water free years wrong with me.
I've been perpetually dehydrated.
If,
if we were alive a hundred years ago,
you'd have died of dysentery,
dysentery.
You thought of that for sure.
No,
I'm not sure I would have died on the
Oregon trail.
No offense.
I would've never left.
I mean like we all pay the fucking game.
It was,
it was ethan died of dysentery.
Terrifying.
Yeah.
That alone shocked me to my core about
moving anywhere,
right?
Like what's the incentive to move
anywhere after playing that game?
That,
what does that mean?
I'm sorry,
I don't want to go anywhere.
Remember when games were on fucking
floppy disks get me,
you know,
like a hunt,
like 1.4,
four megabytes could call it a whole
game.
You guys remember the turtle game stuff
with the little turtle Qwerty or,
yeah,
I remember the turtle turtle where
Qwerty coordinates.
But you could pro programming exercise.
But all I say,
never have ever understood programming
in my life.
So all it was to me was a turtle game
where you tell this little turtle to go,
all right,
go over halfway across the screen,
a little buddy.
And he does it,
but he draws a line behind them.
You all right?
And I'll go down and then you would make
like a star in my case,
I would like make pentagram course.
Of course.
No,
I remember like the turtle game.
Yeah,
I didn't like math blaster and typing
and there was like these sick ass typing
games.
Mavis speed.
Titus.
Yeah.
Maybe chat was not a real person.
Have you guys ever played the newspaper
again?
Where you throw it in?
What's the newspaper boy?
Oh sure,
sure,
sure.
I think that's the first possible was
ever an event like that should be a
great smash fighter.
Oh,
Jack.
If paper will,
it becomes a smash fighter.
I think you should take credit now.
He should be on the record.
What else will they be on?
Yeah,
fuck yeah,
just throwing shit.
Yeah.
I play Mavis beacon online.
Maybe.
You know you got their attention with
that nes video,
so,
oh yeah,
they definitely,
they all want to watch me do it.
Y'All watch that video sucks man.
But they got like,
they got like eight channels,
like a watch.
Y'All want to step this podcast up and
watch me play Mavis beacon live.
Oh my God.
Fuck it up.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a healthy,
that's a how you,
yeah,
they said they got,
they turn into a crazy,
yes.
Wait,
I'm clicking start big or fires out of
five according to the rating.
That's great.
That's a,
that's a solid 80% is you almost have to
evacuate the house with that many damn
proud.
Let's go back.
1987 go back to the lesbians.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Remember we were talking about,
they were about,
I mean,
look how low her blouses that girls have
straight up got shank like I can,
I can almost see her cleavage joke is
that they're not eggs.
We got no,
we got it.
We got it.
Thank you.
The joke is they're clearly yours might
not get it.
We clearly have too many walls up.
I think this necklace is way too
provocative and the fact that she's
drawing attention to her,
that it's drawing away too much
attention to her beautiful neck line and
it's just frankly,
I'm uncomfortable.
I'm,
and I'm getting a little turned on and
it's just,
it's too much.
I know what you think's been dirty.
Skank wearing a necklace like that.
She's a nasty little hose about to go
kiss a lot this week.
I can't wait for the verge.com
disgusting.
It utuber calls another beautiful,
innocent utuber.
Yeah,
that's on you.
You hit play and she's like,
so anyway,
my dad's a lawyer.
Fuck h three calls.
Pure Christian girl.
A skank.
Right.
Thank you.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that going on right
now.
Oh,
she's a skank and oh yeah,
no,
she's fine.
She's okay.
They're fine.
They're joe.
Where's this go home?
You do with that?
I actually could be getting worse
somehow.
US making the biggest fool myself,
my wife,
and that may be so weird because some of
y'all,
you might be like,
I have never heard of that,
but it's actually been a really cool
thing and I'm,
I'm actually really excited about it.
No,
it hasn't.
I'm excited now to get saved,
but when you watch this,
you can get,
I had God's anointing came about.
I'll just always knew when I was a
teenager.
Right.
Both of us.
Yeah.
I remember you read these books by some
Christian authors and they were sharing
about how
I'd feel bad making fun of these girls
need what I,
yeah,
yeah.
I think because it's like,
oh man,
if only they had had a regular
upbringing,
upbringing.
Yeah,
I give you the,
no,
they wouldn't blink of kissing as,
as,
as this,
as this something,
the wheat unholy.
Right,
right.
Absolutely.
Really cool.
Yeah.
Now she does,
but Jesus Christ.
Well she thinks that what is cool.
Waiting,
waiting,
waiting to yes.
Okay.
Cause that's the two different things.
Kissing or waiting to kisses.
Cool.
So that's what I'm always cause he's
excited.
Okay.
And that's fair.
And she never had a summer as a world
where you know,
you're waiting to kids.
That's like Jesus.
That's part of growing up.
Your,
your first kiss when it's like,
you know,
you white boy meets world episode.
Yeah.
Shoves corey up to hang a,
shoves him up against the locker.
Y'All know what I'm talking about.
Thank you.
I know that episode.
That was amazing.
Can we,
I want to say,
do you remember your first kiss era?
Um,
I do.
It was at a summer camp.
Tell me about it.
Give me the details.
I mean it was,
it was like completely embarrassing and
weird and silly.
But like I was super young and it was
like,
all right,
got that out of the way.
Why was that weird?
That's literally exactly what it was.
Yeah.
It was just like,
Oh yeah,
it was 20 counselor last week.
I fired me.
I was a counselor.
I was like,
why was this so weird?
[inaudible]
I was super embarrassed and I really
follow through.
She was super,
I was like,
it was back when I was,
she was into it and I must have been
like 12 that's you and I ran away and I
couldn't do it.
Couldn't fall through,
ran away.
Yes,
because I was too embarrassed.
I couldn't put a pussy because you
weren't awake?
No.
I mean I fucked the shit out of her.
I remember I liked her.
That girl that I,
that I kissed,
it was like,
okay,
we're girl girlfriend,
boyfriend now staying with my grandma to
go to this summer camp and I came home
on the bus from the summer camp and I
was like,
I have a girlfriend.
And then I came home and I went to bed
and woke up,
went to fucking summer camp.
The next day and then like I didn't know
what to do and then she was like sitting
over there and I was sitting over here
with my buddies and I was like,
do I go over there?
And they were like,
I don't know.
We've [inaudible] right.
We're the ones good at sports.
Why the fuck did you and uh,
and then later in the day she walked
over with all of her friends and she was
like,
I decided a,
we're not boyfriend and girlfriend.
I was like,
all right,
I don't blame you.
It was fun.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
You got yours baby.
I was like,
Yo,
I got mine.
And then like shades came out of the
heavens and just the,
because obviously deal with it.
Yeah.
Did you guys do the heart Nicholas's
they're like break into half.
Did you do that with boys?
No,
he did that with boys.
You'd ever tell me that?
Ila,
tell me that stuff.
Jack.
Don't let them know about our,
her necklaces blocked out song.
It'd be weird.
We would,
someone would give it to you and then
you're like girlfriend,
boyfriend.
But it doesn't mean anything like you're
not even know that was a thing.
Tangible pieces of afternoon indicating
that you are,
in fact,
you get lots of offerings.
Do you get half hearts from multiple
boys?
What happens if you get too many
suitors?
I don't even remember anything.
It wasn't anything like that.
What was,
what was your first kiss?
I'm not sure.
I know.
Yeah,
right.
You don't remember your first kiss?
Everyone does.
He does.
You just don't want to talk about it,
but that's fine.
I don't think I remember getting cannot.
Okay,
that's fine.
Let me go.
I'll tell you mine.
I got a juicy one.
I was in,
I was a late bloomer.
Okay.
I'm really thinking about it.
Please,
please.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Let her let her,
let her recollect.
New Ghost stories.
I wasn't risky stores.
I was 16 and I liked a girl who had a
boyfriend.
That wasn't me.
Yeah,
it was juicy,
but she liked me kind of.
Yeah,
she liked me.
So what happened was we went to like,
I went to her house,
but we went to like she happened to have
in her backyard.
She had a creek like,
Woo,
I like where this is going.
It was like in the fall or when go to
and we like wait into the creek a little
bit,
you know,
with like running water and you know,
it's like a brook.
I don't know that there's a bit of work
in the creek,
but it's closed as you relive this
magical moment.
It was the hottest moment of my life,
man.
When I was 69.
Pete.
No.
Um,
so like,
and she had this boyfriend and I did,
she was like,
all right,
close your eyes.
And we kissed while we were in this
brook slash ski show.
That's a beautiful,
magical thing.
And she was like taken,
but she was my first kiss.
She was taken but smitten,
aptly put my friend aptly put,
damn,
you're a fucking pimp dude.
But like beyond that,
so he stayed with him.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I got kicked heavily,
but she was my first kiss.
So in other words,
I got mine.
Oh wait,
was that,
that must have been tough for you.
Uh,
because that's,
uh,
that's some bullshit as a young man to
cock tease like that.
Oh,
absolutely.
I suffered immensely because like,
we both clearly liked each other.
This girl and I,
you know,
I just kind of,
he had a boyfriend,
she was Kinda to time and you know,
but it's like,
you know,
it's,
that's the game of love.
We all play the game of luck.
You just weren't equipped yet to to get
it.
Oh God.
I wasn't equipped for anything.
I was 16.
I was playing smashed my basement,
you know.
Where is she now?
She's still in that creek.
The son of a bitch.
I think she's the one that creek,
I think she's waiting with like Arthur
sword.
Yeah.
Season three of uh,
making a murderer,
I think.
Yeah,
the first and last time she learned her
fucking lesson.
Wouldn't it be hilarious if the new
season of true detective arid and like
Jack is the murderer.
He's,
he's like legally yellow king.
There's an nda where he can't tell us.
We were like doing this podcast and like
we were talking about the new season of
true detective was like joking like,
yeah,
totally.
No,
I don't know what's going to happen.
She was crazy.
Watch the last episode.
It was like a whole tire chains creek.
I had my first kiss.
I somehow gained like 50 pounds for the
roles and all that.
Good.
They're all,
you know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Gained it.
It's all 50 pounds of muscle.
What else?
We got?
Well,
speaking up,
hold on just backtracking a little bit
because we talked about the lovely bones
a little bit.
Oh yeah.
So Ryan Gosling of all people was
supposed to be the villain in the lovely
bones and he gained a significant amount
of weight.
You're supposed to be the villain.
He's supposed to be the villain.
He's about to like the Martin about and
the lovely bones.
It's about a girl who gets raped and
killed.
Oh,
comedy.
And it's from her point of view from
like Evan.
Yeah.
See it.
You never see it.
Like you get it and it's implied.
It's very dark.
But like Ryan Gosling was supposed to be
that guy.
I'm like two teaching Stanley Tucci was
the guy instead of director.
But um,
Ryan,
so Ryan,
I'm sorry,
the whole point is this was a,
this was the til and write it.
This was a today I learned or a movie
details or one of those,
but like Ryan gosling gained literally
30 to 50 pounds.
He never did the art.
They filmed it and Peter Jackson,
the director didn't like this guy.
Can you imagine seeing as I mentioned,
has a fucking actor.
You gained 30 to 50 pounds.
That's a shooting,
a youtube video times.
How can you imagine reshooting a fucking
attitude.
I saw them shit.
I was like a fuck youtube video.
It was just green screens fucking
everywhere.
It was.
It was the scenes where they dumped the,
where he dumps the body into the pit and
the creek or no,
there's like a big trash mold that they,
I know what you're talking about.
He dumps her in a box into the fucking
thing.
Yeah.
I was there for those days and for the
neighborhood days where,
Oh sure.
There's like,
like in the cul de sac of the
neighborhood kind of shit.
It was like in Pennsylvania,
which is the weirdest thing.
I know.
I just get excited because I always
forget.
You're like,
oh boy.
We were dashed place the film of fucking
lovely bones.
I love Philly.
I don't get why you don't love Philly.
That's always rubbed me wrong.
It's not that I don't love it,
it's that I'm done with it.
I mean it's a rough,
it's kind of a rough place in it.
That's the only place I've ever dare
Rafi Duck.
It's in it.
If I get beat up somewhere,
I'm going to leave.
Yeah,
you've been beat up in Philly.
Tell me what's the,
I think he told me you had a
neighborhood kids that were like,
that sounds like a [inaudible].
I thought they were pipes,
but while I was getting beat up upon you
and collection,
they were pieces of bicycle killed a
bicyclist and and then Luna,
his body,
like the fallout,
so like rebar and you were the bat
flight pieces.
He used that to hit me a bunch of times
right before I was about to move into
this place.
And I was like,
all right,
I'm just going to move in there and I'm
not going to do it.
No,
that's why you don't want some pipe
wielding little punks.
Ah
sucked.
You got to stay with us.
Stay with us next time we go to Philly,
man.
Philly's a great,
well why do you go to Philly?
Yeah,
I mean,
so my,
so Erin,
my wife is,
is from failure,
you know,
like sheet will,
she's from a town just outside of Philly
by me.
Like she spent a lot,
she's lived in fit like in downtown
Philly and um,
early on,
like romy just started dating in early
2013.
Um,
I like lived with her in her apartment
in Philly for a month and it goes,
but it was one of those things where
like I was just kinda like hanging out
with her for,
because she had come out to la to like
visit me.
I hang out with me for a week.
So I returned the favor of the following
year in early 2013 to hang out with her
in Philly.
And it was just supposed to be a week
and then a week turned into two weeks,
three weeks,
and then a whole month over month.
Um,
but it's just,
it's a hell of,
it's just such a fun,
you walk everywhere,
unlike La,
you can't fucking walk anywhere in La
unless you're in downtown,
but no ones in downtown.
You can walk anywhere in Philadelphia.
It's a very walkable city.
There's so much to do.
We went out to dinner just about every
single,
like a different place every night
because like,
it's just,
there's so much to do in Philly.
Why doesn't seem to crossover with your
anecdote?
Well,
I mean,
I have plenty of good things to say
about Philadelphia,
but they're all after I left,
none of them happened while I lived in a
damn shame area.
Uh,
you gotta you like La,
like we moved out of there.
My parents moved us out of Philly when I
was 12,
11,
something like that because,
uh,
I'm a gangster got shot outside of our
house or a mobster.
That's terrifying.
That's a Ma like Italian mafia.
You had a rough neighborhood?
No,
not at all.
But there was FBI in some of the
apartments that were like no shit
watching us because at the end of our
block,
um,
I grew up in at fifth and Katherine in
Philadelphia and it was a,
uh,
a takeover of the mob scene at the time.
This Guy Joey Morlino.
Hmm.
And this other guy,
Chink Illini,
um,
and shingle Leni had an older brother
who was with the current heads of the,
of the mob.
And so these,
these younger boys put out a hit on the
older brother.
He got shot,
went to a hospital.
The hospital was where my father worked
at the time.
And these guys put the hit out from
apparently the end of the block where I
lived on.
So my dad's over here at this hospital.
They bring in Alenia.
It's always like we're mobsters in the
hallway and shit.
And then,
um,
meanwhile at my house,
my mom has somebody like a patient over
that she's talking to.
And so in retaliation for the hit to put
that guy in the hospital,
they come over and just start firing at,
uh,
the guys at the end of the block who by
the way,
it used to be a green piece.
And then this,
uh,
junior mafia took over and they turn it
into an exterminators,
which is I think one of the funniest
reversals,
I guess a classic comedy reversal right
there.
But anyway,
they shot the shit out of these guys.
Jordan,
me,
Alina got shot in the ass.
A bunch of people died on your street.
One person died,
uh,
I think it was tingling and his brother,
this younger guy died.
And then this is,
by the way,
I'm,
I'm not a wikipedia article for this,
so if I'm wrong,
it doesn't make the whole thing wrong.
That just makes like that part wrong.
This escalate the shingle,
ng war.
No,
it was pretty much over it because it
was just like,
what the fuck?
And then as far as like I was concerned
or my family was concerned because,
uh,
I think our house was already on the
market when that happened.
But once that happened,
it really put a fire under my parents
asked to like,
get the fuck out of their trouble
selling.
After that happened.
I doubt it because it was like,
now if you go to that neighborhood,
it's beautiful.
But at the time it was just these,
these fucking,
uh,
got moocs.
Is that a word?
It is now,
man.
He's got Moocs,
silver on the end of the street.
It get the fucking exterminated.
They're the ones getting exterminated.
I realized how I,
I don't think I realized how good
fellows Merlino was in fucking prison
right now.
They found him as,
as,
as high profile as this guy was,
by the way.
He was like limping away with a bullet
in his ass.
And uh,
they found him under someone's bed when
they were coming to arrest them.
And I remember that from the news.
They kicked someone's door and there was
this movie going to be right.
I want to watch it.
Yeah.
I mean Lyngee Hey,
at least they didn't.
Fire volume gets more fun.
Glad they use bullets in that movie
written.
From your perspective,
my perspective would be like an eight
year old comes home and they're loading
a body into an ambulance and the eight
year olds like,
oh,
he's still got an Nintendo.
Don't care at all.
Yeah.
It's like the worst movie ever.
What's that?
Nothing.
Get the getting the fucking house right.
What does that looks like?
A dead body?
No,
no,
no.
Again,
inside get inside,
we're having,
I'm always amazed looking back on my
capacity to not give a fuck when I was a
kid.
Yeah.
Like no matter what awful thing was
happening in the world,
I just didn't care at all.
Well,
you're a priority,
not,
yeah.
Your brain's wired.
You know,
we've pretty much reached the end of our
document.
We've got reached the end of the
[inaudible].
Well,
we got got the pod.
You meant well,
we've got bacon.
Vending machine.
Okay.
We also have eric reacts to a Youtube
rewind.
No,
I had a,
I had a pitch for you guys.
That's the rewind that I would love to
just get a brief out there on.
Um,
I was making sure that I wasn't getting
a text message from my dad being like,
don't talk about that.
Oh,
nice.
Cause I remember the last time I was on,
he was like,
I remember that.
Let's all check our phones.
Do we have notes from my notes from my
parents?
My parents,
usually they do have something to say
every once in a while.
I have,
I don't have anything from your parents.
However,
I do have a quick summary of answers for
all of the furry questions we had
earlier in the episode.
Yes.
Pooped.
Hell,
you better had fun at the park.
Were there about an hour?
Just returned from a walk.
Shredder pooped.
I'm trying to feed him now.
Do you guys use the APP?
That's really exciting.
The Dog Walker.
My mom,
I don't trust strange.
That's way better.
We love shutter.
Tell me about the firies if you would
please.
Okay.
So,
um,
uh,
a gentleman with a little furry avatar
named Dan reached out.
Yup.
Dan.
Uh,
just some real simple bullet pointed
answers.
Here's furries.
Uh,
or like any fandom,
the way I like to think about is
basically saying that furries are all
about sex is like saying everyone who
watches anime like Hentai.
Okay,
hold on.
Let me,
let me put a stop.
First of all,
fandom of what furries sand them of you.
I think his point is just saying that
it's a diverse,
uh,
fandom there in that it's not a
monolith.
There are different sex in it,
if you will.
So is being a furry putting on a suit?
Like where does,
because that seems like an extreme.
So where does furry is him start?
I think it's the light for a minute.
I think the suit is a requirement.
I think that's kind of the baseline.
That's,
that's an extreme.
That's not like watching anime,
that's getting an a suit and going
meeting people.
Well,
hold on.
He,
uh,
he addresses that.
So,
um,
and again,
furry people,
I'm not,
I'm just,
I'm trying to understand.
Carry it.
It's an unusual thing.
Three people I know and I,
and I don't want to be that guy.
You are,
but I do have a 250 Iq and I'm trying to
stress my massive intellect.
What's it like up there?
That view.
So go ahead please.
Down.
Uh,
so he says he does agree many fursuits
of specially the faces and eyes are
definitely kind of creepy or off in some
way,
but they're super expensive and the
nicer they are the price here.
Um,
so I guess he's saying,
you know,
the cheap ones are going to look
creepier.
I think it's just an uncanny thing cause
it's like a Fox humanoid,
Eh got pleased Dan,
if you could put if you yeah,
sure.
And so,
uh,
he says on that note,
since they're so expensive and hard to
clean,
most people who own them,
we don't,
kids may not have sex in them,
right?
There are even some drama in the past
where people were saying that those who
do have sex in their suits shouldn't
them in public.
Uh,
but who knows how that argument ended.
So a Mongol,
how many,
so how many fandoms are there arguments
amongst themselves about wearing their
suits,
having sex in their suits?
Like it's clearly a part of,
it's definitely an aspect that she's not
denying that comes suit.
I would want to come,
it's a come spent all this money on a
suit.
I'm going to just go over.
Well,
you're a funny,
do you want to mark your territory?
Sorry,
go ahead.
I think the animate comparison is apt in
that he's saying,
you know,
like myself,
I enjoy anime but I'm not into the
Hentai aspect of it,
which is sort of like,
it's a subculture within a subculture.
Okay.
The people that are that it's super
sexual for within the furry community.
That's just one section.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
and then he says a bad dream.
This is a different person also talks
about bad dragon is basically a website
that makes weird sex toys more,
mostly marketed towards furries.
Those wearable things are basically like
a dildo that goes around your deck.
So there you go.
So you don't get any,
well,
you don't get any physical,
well I guess the person wearing it
doesn't cause the debt is way fucking
nicer than your own others.
He can get electrodes.
Does it just give you,
well yeah,
I've got a guy,
I got a prop deck that it's show,
it looks like a creature from shape of
water.
Oh sure.
Awesome.
Fantastic.
I just,
I just shocked at myself in the deck
with it on and film it for fiber.
They don't,
I interestingly,
uh,
I've killed a couple people with it and
so the bad dragon is a,
is a penis modification that looks at
like an animals.
Well,
bad dragon,
I guess it's just a website.
Not a website is sold.
Various different antibiotic.
I have a good check it out of your own.
Tiny little pathetic human penis.
But for those of you at home,
the bad dragon.com,
Pakistan will love that.
And then,
uh,
his final point here is that not
everyone who likes furries really buys
into the fandom.
Some people really live it like with any
fandom,
but some people just like it and don't
really go to conventions.
What do that?
I just,
what are they fans of dressing up is
animals.
I mean,
cosplay,
cosplay.
But it was play.
What I'm missing is I feel like there's
an Oregon cozy play.
I feel like there's an origin to this
that we're not understanding.
I got your point.
Yeah.
What's the origin?
Where does it come from?
There's got to be cosplaying.
Like how did people decide that they
loved dressing up like foxes?
Like what's the origin?
There's got to be a show or a TV.
Music.
Yeah.
What's the first piece of entertainment
where the main character was an
anthropomorphic animal?
Fox.
Felix the cat.
It was a winnie the Pooh and just him
walking around without no pants.
Mickey had a lot of people were like,
Yo,
I want to know the origin.
That's the big next too.
Because uh,
you know,
the,
the furry thing,
it's all animals,
but like it seems,
and I could be wrong about this,
but it seems like 80% of that,
it's all foxes.
Yeah.
It's all foxes.
So there's something going on there.
We'll foxes are sexy.
One of the sexier animals.
Yeah.
You know,
like a,
you look at the,
Oh,
do it.
You look at a Fox and try not to get
horny.
What's the sexiest Fox though?
I'm the one from the Fox and the hound.
Right.
What am I thinking of?
Disney?
Yeah.
What Fox mccloud from smash.
I don't think I've seen that.
That's like one of those old,
like from the 60s animated.
I'm classics of Disney.
The Fox and the hound.
No,
I'm,
well I'm more of
the uh,
tramp and lady and the lady.
Yeah.
More of a,
I don't think there are any foxes in
that movie.
I would come on the trip.
We know the,
the tramp would,
is that not a dry,
I'd have to get him back to like a skank
it.
So it used to mean something different.
So,
so,
um,
uh,
Charlie Chaplin played the lovable
tramp.
Like his character was a tramp and it
was just kind of like a,
it meant something different back in the
day.
When I sit back in the day,
I mean like in the fucking 20s,
30s,
I apologize if that's not quite the
right timeline,
but,
um,
it,
it used to mean something.
So lady and the tramp did not mean like,
cause it was lady,
the lady dog.
And then tramp was like this homeless,
kind of like a vagabond and little guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so it meant something different.
So today in today's standard,
you know,
tramp stamp,
that's obviously a derogatory term for
that.
Oh,
is he making a movie called like lady
and the Skank skanking a bottle.
Yeah.
Going to be there next CGI,
a live action remake after Aladdin and
after Milan
after I got to know what's,
what the fuck?
Oh ilos I'll look it very,
I mean,
you can look it up easily.
The furry fandom is a subculture
interested in and throw poor morphic
animal characters.
We'd human personalities and
characteristics.
But why Laos?
Fox Is,
you're right Dan.
They're all Fox and there's two,
but mostly Fox.
The Fox thing seems to,
that's the number one rate boxes is
sexy.
Blame for frame here.
All right,
let's see what we've got.
We've got all of the good stuff.
We never,
we never did watch the,
uh,
the married,
that married twins.
Fuck the skanks.
I want to pitch something.
You cramps.
She's tramps.
They can go kick rocks.
I mean either vetoing this.
Do you think that's a dangerous watch?
No,
I'm just saying it doesn't go anywhere.
There's no,
it's just that I'm talking about you.
You think they do and there's a lot of
crow.
Do you know that lot?
There's a lot of,
uh,
religious girls who don't have sex
because it's forbidden
until they get married.
But they,
they take it up.
The Bot.
If you guys heard about the animals
really soaking,
what does that mean?
That is a mormon thing.
Where before you're allowed to actually
have sex,
you can insert,
but just leave it there.
You can't go in and out and away.
It's soaking wet.
You mean the penis?
Google.
Mormon Solo.
Are you talking about a penis or a toy?
Penis or allow his penis in the vagina.
But as long as you don't move,
it's all dogs.
You don't move fast.
One on God.
Yeah,
I'm into that.
No,
no.
That's a shortcut.
Stoke Google that Google is soaking you
get,
first of all,
there's no way that you can soak and not
end up fucking,
so there's,
there is games called fear of God.
No,
no.
You guys know just a tip.
Yes.
Yeah.
Just a tip.
Never ever ends with the guy not coming.
Like just the tip is always like the
guy.
He's like,
hey,
hey baby.
You want it?
Like just a tip.
And then they like,
you know,
he's like,
but he's like us.
The tip I usually just 20% doing.
Anyway,
my Dick,
let's give a good pit now.
Right now,
I wish we were watching that video.
I wish I was downhill.
That was the most entertaining video of
tonight.
I will say,
God,
I hope he's a new smash plc.
We're getting five new characters in
2019 pd.
Parotid plant is,
the number of characters are,
they're like on Munch unlaunched.
There's like,
Oh,
you only get 70 70 I think,
or something like that.
You have to unlock.
You only get home.
You get when you like.
Oh gotcha.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
And you have to unlock the rest of it.
In total at launch there are over 70
there's like 74 that's going to be like
a hundred and fucking 50 by the end of
2019 well,
let's pray that fill that bag up.
Makes the cut.
That would be a lawnmower.
W what's the subreddit for the for that,
because I'm going to have to filter it
out because I don't want to see a god
damn announcement for a new character
every two weeks.
Well,
you,
well,
you're not seeing it.
You ain't got a problem.
All right.
Right.
It's just a hat.
You got up.
You wouldn't be excited for hat new
challenger.
Right,
right,
right.
Newt Gingrich.
That'd be fucking Newt Gingrich.
Fat Fingers,
Melodies Berg.
He's really trying to get in with the
kids.
Yeah,
because that's what gets me,
right.
I guess.
Let's wrap it up.
It's been,
sorry,
it's been $1 million idea for spent
almost three hours,
but I'll pick this pick.
Let's,
let's make it the three.
I'm very excited about this.
So you guys were talking about the
youtube rewind.
I don't give a shit about that.
Right,
the rewind itself,
but next year I really want to see an h
three wind,
h three one where you hit up.
All your friends were to me saying they
make the video that everybody wanted to
see.
Why Youtube got to make
the video.
I don't think I'm the guy for that.
I eat or on the pulse.
You got,
you got people to help you out.
You got people coordinated.
Rewind h three wine.
The name is kind of too good to pass on.
That is a good idea.
It should be like everyone who slipped
up and said the n word.
I'll happily say the outward getting
that video on make it ends in a,
I'll do a quick roll.
Instagram and pie by Edward compilation
h three one and work on page three wine.
I just,
I'm just saying I want to put it out
there.
Think about it.
Jack.
Looks like he wants to make that n word
cut right now.
I'll talk.
Let's wrap.
I'm sober Dan.
No,
I think that's a great idea.
Each three wine 2019 youtube can make
whatever they want.
They're going to make something weird
that's a really good hitters to a
certain demographic that they're happy
about.
Just everyone the same date.
I think so,
yeah.
When it comes out,
yeah,
I didn't,
but I think there,
there's gotta be some method to the
madness.
Here's my reason for wanting this is
that like so many people seem to give a
shit,
right?
Yeah.
Why do you,
why do you honestly fucking care what
this website makes?
I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you exactly why.
Because it affects us all.
I Eric.
Okay.
It affects,
and if it looks bad,
one,
it looks bad to all of us.
It's a lot of like,
was it like 10 million dislikes or
whatever.
It turned into a meme.
Really let them make whatever the hell
they want.
But I think the,
it's hard not to care.
I don't know why.
It's just the burden of making a good
one should not be on them because
clearly they're not in the only thing.
They dropped the ball.
The burden of making it go and she'd be
on it requires a lot of resources,
a lot of coordinating that you can do.
I can't get like I can't get,
you can do it year round,
year round.
Anytime you get a guest on the podcast,
get there,
you know?
No,
I'm going to veto that.
It's gotta be at the end of the year.
I'm sorry.
Like I see what you're going,
but it's gotta be like a lot of annual
thing I think to me,
I just,
you know,
I don't,
it's a lot of responsibility,
Eric,
and I'm really stressed out already just
thinking about it.
I guarantee,
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not to say all be all or anything
like that,
but a go,
let's make a poll.
Oh,
I was going to say,
yeah,
well yeah.
[inaudible] you make the rewind.
Let's take a poll.
All right.
But I don't have a catchy name for it.
It's the,
the,
it's the youtube,
the h three wind right off the tongue.
It really does.
Ace three threes,
even like a backwards z.
We're going to think of one.
If it's the he whined the he wine baby,
do the h three one.
I wish I could if I wish I could be
wine.
Yeah.
What would yours be,
Eric?
Uh,
it would start with will smith Gallia
I'd be like a really poorly done g
version of him.
And then it melts into a puddle and then
in the puddle you see the planet Nibiru
coming around the sun and then it soaks
up all the oceans of earth of this.
This is you.
This is totally off the cuff.
And then,
and then what happens is,
is uh,
Steve Bannon is riding one of those
waves up towards the sun and he turns to
the camera and he says something
incredibly hateful but poignant.
Everyone agrees with,
he just drops the animal with a hardy
are low and,
and,
and purposeful.
And then like a check get shot at him
and he catches it right before it kills
him and he slowly and search it and his
ass.
And you see it close up.
You see it?
Yeah.
I'm just saying that 20,
19 you guys three hours.
And then Susan comes out and says,
now that's a rewind.
You hire those two women from earlier.
Yeah,
that's a really wide,
oh fuck,
oh no.
God Damn Greater.
Then just cut it off.
Yeah.
Dan at Dan's been texting me,
by the way.
He's been hitting me up on our little
office cat that will wrap it up.
He goes,
let's wrap it up.
He keeps blood up.
Well,
where's all ship?
Our Life?
We're getting Henny,
right.
Hashtag h street wind,
everybody spamming shadow.
There'll be forced to.
There's really no choice here.
Do you think will smith?
We'll do a rewind for me.
I think it might as well just give me
one of these.
Ah,
do you notice that he does not notice
that?
I don't know if that was
you're describing it as that.
I don't know if that's entirely
insensitive.
Thanks.
No thanks.
So I think I don't even know where
you're talking about.
Well he does.
He goes like,
ah,
no.
I think it was like,
I think it was like a um,
uh,
R and b hip hop,
like old school rba.
Nobody's trying so hard not to act
because I,
like I said,
this is the,
this is the performance of his career
because nobody has had to try to pretend
to like fortnight and youtube much as
will smith has.
His opening line is I want fortnight and
Mark Keys Brown.
So you do know,
you do know where you want to fucking
lie.
Yeah.
Watch the first 45 years and then I
just,
the by the way they promote it.
It's like everywhere.
Oh,
they lie.
They cheat.
They're,
you know,
they shut that shit with mark.
He's Brown in the bus before the got
will smith because he just looks into
the camera and he's like,
is this what you wanted?
Yeah.
It's all you can think about is like,
all right,
whoever we get,
you're going to say I want fortnight and
Tana,
Mohan Gill,
right?
Ah,
I don't know.
Well,
I just don't know about this one.
Ah,
he directed or you on is where you are
on time.
It's almost like a goat who sounds like
a man.
So how do I know that?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
You think he's mad that they didn't give
him like proper direction?
Like No.
Like do you think he had final approval
over this or did he stop in the release
right away?
Well Smith probably fucking
did.
He probably,
cause if I was bill Smith I would be
like,
we got it.
We should be part of it.
I think he's legit happy to be a part of
rewind because like he,
I checked this channel out and he is
like legit trying to delve into the
youtube world.
And I think like just any involvement,
I mean that any involvement in rewind,
he is very happy to get,
I agree.
Like he's in his,
in his um,
channel trailer.
He says like you two has reinvigorated
me.
It's getting to light and to be fair I
think that's fucking cool.
Like I mean,
yeah,
one hand it's like,
ah,
it's an alias,
a triple a list,
Hollywood star getting into youtube.
But on the other hand,
like if it gets him excited,
like I can't fault them for that because
they don't put an ad for sal allergy.
I'm cool.
Exactly.
Oh dianetics Yah.
I'm raising my kids in a cryo chamber.
God Damn,
I don't have a problem with them being
on Youtube.
Yeah.
At all.
I mean for us,
of course.
Yeah.
But like,
like man shit,
what was it last year?
Was it the rock?
It was the wrong one or two years ago
was the rock.
I forget which one.
Like he opens a fan.
How active is the rock on Youtube now?
Like that was a good batting fucking
passwords.
A youth to fully supports.
He never knew.
Right,
right.
He never knew it.
Yeah,
of course that,
but like we'll rewind,
I would want fortnight.
I also the premise of this video,
so exactly.
That's a DAB bubble moment.
Absolutely.
But the premise is like that will smith
is in charge of rewind.
It's like it's all you baby.
You're the one,
you're neil.
Yeah.
That wasn't the best year to make it.
It's like whoever watches,
well I'm charged for rewind.
Yeah.
And it's like a fucking fever dream.
Like he dropped acid and then
hallucinates it should be little
coordinate bus from the bag man thing.
Baghdad.
Oh,
it'd be bad if I was a controller.
Rewind.
I would be back that shit.
And the Christian girls do anal.
Yeah.
I don't know what you guys have against
who's the rewind would be fucking
amazing.
Let's h three wine,
this podcast please.
Hell yeah,
but we're only after this.
This is what you wanted as the,
and then he's talking to,
well it's like,
yeah,
well what do we all just singing and
dancing?
Tried to impress will Smith,
is this what you wanted?
Well
apparently according to Marcus Brownley
he,
they shot like hours of footage for
this.
But of course you only see like mere
seconds.
So like I think they had a lot of
different options,
which are the charters were you in last
years I was in line or in the dance
scene,
right?
Yeah.
There was like a second.
Have you,
did you know going in two years?
Two years ago there was like a frame of
me last year there was a slight smidge
more,
I think I remember seeing two years ago,
I did not know I would be like that cut
out of it two years ago.
I had no fucking clue I had no,
it's just one of those like you're there
all day and make the most of it and you
hope and you pray that some smidge of
you makes it into the final cut.
That's all it is.
And they never guarantee it until like
the day of fucking comes out.
Right.
Because they,
they have editors and they have notes.
They have producers.
So many different things.
The way they're very brand focused with
this whole thing.
The entire thing is an advertisement.
It is to advertisers.
It's the show how,
how safe we are healing.
We are,
you're going to make it.
They're like,
oh my God will smith.
Exactly.
And so like,
yeah,
everyone,
myself included,
made fun of Youtube rewind for like,
Oh will smith,
he's my favorite youtube pause for
laughter.
But at the same time it's very appealing
to see this triple a list or Hollywood
star in this thing because that's all it
is.
It's an,
it's an advertisement and I can't fault
Youtube rewind reporter lay for that.
I mean they got to do what they gotta do
and that's all I'm saying.
And as long as people don't expect
anything better.
Right.
Because I feel like they have a seat of
power,
crazy person because this thing came out
and everybody hated it and I was like,
wait,
you shocked you fucking surprise this.
Well,
that's because these two pointed out in
your excellent recap video that youtube
rewind wasn't always this totally
hateable thing.
In fact,
it used to be quite likable.
It's funny that I'm diving into being a
complete asshole here because I've
always said,
no,
it's not you being an asshole.
It's just you'd be in fucking ignorant.
That's what it is.
They're a fucking EPK EPK electronic
press kit.
It's just the fucking way to show
you,
right?
You've been on set,
you've been on set before.
It's nonsense.
It's a fucking nonsense thing.
If you watch it and you're not an
investor,
you're wasting as well.
Like they're,
yeah,
they got everybody,
but,
but they didn't though.
They didn't get a lot of people that's
not like funny or entertaining.
They didn't get a lot of key players
that like Shane Dawson for example,
like he is like like him or not.
He was a huge part of youtube this year.
A lot of people.
Yeah and a lot of people.
Right.
It's not to shame.
I thought people,
I think next year it's going to be
awesome because they've got nothing to
lose.
I think next year is going to rock more.
It's going to be Susan on her back of
taking a giant check mark in the ass and
being like is this what you wanted?
Yeah,
super closeup.
Hairy asshole.
Cause she's a MILF,
right?
She's in the middle of the it.
He's in the milk category.
This term is that the baby's babies.
So you see a lot more than you borrowed.
We're starting the and then it's just
her.
I'd like to apologize for everything you
can hurt.
They know.
So is this what you wanted?
Half a bottle of Bourbon and Scotch with
will smith tried to drown him.
Starts Will Smith and he goes to,
if I can show it we wide,
it wouldn't be Susan.
What jetski honor back,
making it up the ass with a verified
check mark.
I knew she would be like,
and she'd be like,
is this what you wanted?
Well,
floppy mom tips.
Put a camera on here next Tuesday.
We got a charity stream and her floppy
mom laying on her stomach.
Awesome.
On the chair.
It is termed don't miss it.
You guys are going to get towards your
Joey Salads.
Yeah.
It's going to be next week on Tuesday.
No,
seriously.
Money and cruise day.
It's going to be huge.
It's gonna be one of our,
our biggest last year we raised 240,000
this year we're going to top it because
we've got tons of amazing stuff to give
away.
We've got Joey Salads back in the studio
to torture for our amusement.
We've got so much amazing stuff.
Rick and morty exclusive march,
age three historical March,
and if you play your cards right,
you might see Susan Wichinski with a
floppy man to watch joey cells die.
He's Mister Rick and morty.
He is brick and I'm just kidding.
Nobody wants love Susan.
She tries her best and she's good at
her.
She's really crazy.
Justin Reuland isn't music playing?
Yeah.
Okay,
so that wraps,
this concludes this episode of the boys
are back in Dan Jack Films,
the legend.
Thank you so much.
I wish you well.
Just keep working,
man.
Don't just keep,
she's keeping Brian to,
hey,
you're going to work your way to the
rot.
It's inevitable.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey,
just keep grinding baby boy right back
at you to the both of you and to you as
well,
but you don't need my help.
Hey,
thanks so much.
Just make a video every once in a while.
I'll be happy.
You said don't know.
Float more once a month is good.
Once a week.
Oh right.
We all know that.
We've got two more episodes this year,
so you don't,
you won't want to miss it.
The hangover aid,
just like aerosmith page.
Thanks for watching.
If you want one,
that's the one miss you,
babe.
Don't cup.
Write the song and all right.
Just faded.